THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE NUMBER ONE ON HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES. TODAY WE
WILL TAKE ACTION ON THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND MAY
REVISION PROPOSALS FOR HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES PROGRAMS. I
HAVE BEEN ASKED TO READ SOME
DIRECTIONS REGARDING PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION IN TODAY'S
HEARING TO HELP INSURE THE
SAFETY OF EVERYONE HERE TODAY
WHILE ALLOWING FULL PUBLIC
ACCESS TO THE DISCUSSION. WE
ARE ACCEPTING PUBLIC COMMENT AT
THE END OF THIS HEARING BOTH IN
THE HEARING ROOM AND ON THE
PHONE. THE PHONE NUMBER TO
CONNECT IS ON THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AND SHOULD BE ON THE
SCREEN IF YOU ARE WATCHING OVER
THE INTERNET. THE NUMBER IS.
1-877-692-8957 AND THE PUBLIC
ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN. TODAY WE
ARE ACTING ON MANY OF THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET AND
MAY REVISE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES PROPOSALS NOT ALL
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSALS WILL
BE ACTED ON TODAY AS SOME ARE
STILL UNDER DISCUSSION AND WILL
BE HELD OPEN AND VOTED ON IN
FULL BUDGET COMMITTEE NEXT
WEEK. MEMBER AND STAKEHOLDER
PROPOSALS WILL NOT BE ACTED ON
IN TODAY'S HEARING BUT INSTEAD
WILL BE MAY BE ACTED ON DURING
NEXT WEDNESDAY'S FULL BUDGET
COMMITTEE HEARING.
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE SENATE
AND THE ADMINISTRATION ARE
ONGOING AS ALWAYS AND WE
CONTINUE TO WELCOME PUBLIC
INPUT ON ALL ASPECTS OF THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
BUDGET. BEFORE WE START I'D
LIKE TO THANK EVERYONE FOR ALL
THE HARD WORK. THAT HAS BEEN
DONE TO GET US HERE. WE ARE
FORTUNATE TO HAVE RESOURCES BUT
MUST ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THIS
PANDEMIC HAS NOT HIT US ALL
EQUALLY. WE MUST LOOK FOR WAYS
WITHIN SOME WANT TO SUPPORT OUR
MOST VULNERABLE POPULATIONS I
LOOK FORWARD TO SUPPORTING THE
BUDGET THAT MAKES HEALTH CARE
ACCESSIBLE TO AS MANY PEOPLE AS
POSSIBLE ONE THAT PROVIDES
EMERGENCY FOOD AND ADDRESSES
GROWING HUNGER. ONE THAT
ADDRESSES THE UNDER FUNDING AND
OUR DEVELOPMENTAL. SERVICES
SYSTEM AND ONE THAT TAKES BOLD
ACTION TO NOT ONLY DISRUPT BUT
TO BREAK DOWN SYSTEMIC RACISM
BAKED INTO THE STATE'S HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES PROGRAMS.
THIS BUDGET WILL CONTINUE TO
PRIORITIZE INVESTMENTS THAT
FOCUS ON PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION AND THAT MOVE US
UPSTREAM TO PROACTIVELY FACE
MANY OF THE COMPLEX AND VEXING
PROBLEMS IN OUR STATE. I AM
GRATEFUL TO THE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE TO LEGISLATIVE
LEADERSHIP AND THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PUT THIS BUDGET
FORWARD. I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING THE CONVERSATION
OVER THE NEXT FEW WEEKS AS WE
HELP TO DELIVER A BUDGET THAT
WE CAN ALL BE PROUD OF. A
BUDGET THAT STANDS FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. A CALIFORNIA FOR
ALL. THE ALL HERE IS IMPORTANT
AS THE HEALTH OF EACH OF US IS
DEPENDENT ON THE HEALTH OF ALL
OF US. DURING THE GREAT
DEPRESSION WE SAW GOVERNMENT
STEP IN AND PROVIDE SUPPORT FOR
THOSE WHO ARE MOST VULNERABLE
AND WHO FELL THROUGH THE SOCIAL
SAFETY NET. BY INVESTING IN ALL
AMERICANS THROUGH PROGRAMS LIKE
SOCIAL SECURITY WE CAME OUT
STRONGER AND BETTER THAN BEFORE.
NOW IS THE TIME FOR CALIFORNIA
TO DO THE SAME BY STEPPING UP
LEADING AND INVESTING IN ALL
CALIFORNIANS. IN THIS PANDEMIC
OF THE CENTURY WE SAW
DISPARITIES BEAR OUT IN OUR
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND WE
MUST USE THIS MOMENT AS AN
ACCELERATED FOR CHANGE SO THAT
ALL OF US CAN RISE OUT OF THIS
PANDEMIC STRONGER THAN EVER. WE
MUST SUPPORT AND RESOURCE OUR
COMMUNITIES PARTICULARLY R. L.
INTELLECTUALLY AND
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR TO ADDRESS
THE HISTORICAL AND CURRENT
INEQUITIES AND DISPARITIES. AS
WE LOOK TO STRENGTHEN OUR
SOCIAL SAFETY NET WE SHOULD
LOOK TOWARDS PROGRAMS THAT
INVEST IN EQUITY PROGRAMS THAT
ADDRESS THE SOCIAL DETERMINANTS
OF HEALTH AND CONTINUE OUR
STATE'S MOVEMENT TOWARDS HEALTH
FOR ALL. I AM REMINDED OF MLK'S
WORDS THAT THE ARC OF THE MORAL
UNIVERSE IS LONG. BUT IT BENDS
TOWARD JUSTICE WITH THAT LET US
BEGIN. CAN WE PLEASE ESTABLISH
CORE. ARAMBULA PRESENT FONG
FRAZIER MATHIS HERE RAMOS RUBIO
WOOD. THANK YOU WE WILL NOW
BEGIN VOTING AND WE WILL BATCH
THE ITEMS IF THAT'S OKAY WE
WILL BE I WILL BE SEEKING A
MOTION AND A SECOND ON THE
FOLLOWING ISSUES FOR PART AA
ISSUES TWO THROUGH.
579-312-1517. EIGHTEEN. TWENTY
ONE THREE TWENTY NINE THIRTY
FIVE THROUGH. THIRTY NINE FORTY
ONE FORTY THREE THROUGH. FORTY
SEVEN FORTY NINE FIFTY FIFTY
THREE THROUGH. FIFTY FIVE FIFTY
SEVEN THREE SIXTY THREE SIXTY
FIVE THROUGH SIXTY SEVEN.
697-273-7670. 783-919-3390 FIVE
DO I HAVE A MOTION. CAN WE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ARAMBULA
HI FRAZIER HI. MATHIS FONG HI
RAMOS- RUBIO WOOD HI. I'D NOW
LIKE TO BATCH AND I'M SEEKING A
MOTION AND A SECOND FOR ISSUES
NUMBER THIRTY TWO SEVENTY FIVE
AND NINETY EIGHT. WE'LL CALL.
CAN WE PLEASE CALL ROLL
ARAMBULA HI FRAZIER HI MATHIS.
FONG NO RAMOS- RUBIO WOULD.
THANK YOU WE WERE NOW I WILL
SEEK A ON THE SIDE ON ISSUES.
FIFTY ONE SEVENTY SEVENTY EIGHT
THROUGH SEVENTY NINE. SECOND
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ARAMBULA I.
FRAZIER HI MATHIS. FONG ANOTHER
ALMOST RUBIO WOOD HI. TO
CONCLUDE THIS AGENDA WE WILL I
WILL SPEAK OF MOTION AND A
SECOND ON- ISSUE NUMBER SIXTY
EIGHT SOME OF- PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ARAMBULA HI FRAZIER BY.
MATHIS. FONG ANOTHER. RAMOS
RUBIO WOULD. I AM SEEKING A
MOTION ON THE SECOND ON ISSUE
NUMBER SEVENTY ONE. SECOND
TWENTY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ARAMBULA HI FRAZIER HI MATHIS.
FONG ANOTHER. RAMOS RUBIO WOULD.
I BELIEVE THAT CONCLUDES PART A
OF THE AGENDA WE WILL HOLD IT
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS WE WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO PART B. OF THE
AGENDA. I AM GOING TO SEEK A
MOTION AND A SECOND ON THIS
FIRST BATCH WHICH INCLUDES
ISSUES ONE. FOUR NINE. ELEVEN
THROUGH THIRTEEN. FIFTEEN
THROUGH SEVENTEEN. TWENTY
TWENTY THREE THROUGH.
262-931-3330 FIVE THROUGH
THIRTY NINE. 414-024-0540 SIX
FORTY EIGHT THROUGH FIFTY TO.
FIFTY FOUR THROUGH SIXTY TWO
AND SIXTY FOUR THROUGH SEVENTY
SIX TO HAVE A MOTION. CAN WE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ARAMBULA
HI FONG. FRAZIER HI MATHIS-
RAMOS RUBIO WOULD. WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO ISSUES. EIGHT THIRTY
FOUR FORTY THREE FORTY FOUR AND
FORTY SEVEN DO I HAVE A MOTION
TO MOVE. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ARAMBULA HI FONG. FONG NOT
VOTING FRAZIER HI MATHIS.
MATHIS NOT VOTING RAMOS. RUBIO
WOULD. HAS. FOR WE WILL NOW I
WILL NOW ASK FOR A MOTION AND A
SECOND ON ISSUE NUMBER FORTY.
SECOND PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ARAMBULA HI FONG. FRAZIER
MATHIS RAMOS RUBIO WOULD. HAS.
SIX WE WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS- BEFORE WE
CONCLUDE TODAY I WANT TO SAY A
LITTLE MORE ABOUT THE DIRECTION
THAT THE SUBCOMMITTEE AND THE
ASSEMBLY ARE WORKING ON TO
BUILD AND FUND AS WE WORK
TOWARDS ACTION NEXT WEEK AND
FULL BUDGET COMMITTEE I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE AND APPRECIATE THE
ADMINISTRATION AND GOVERNOR'S
LEADERSHIP ON WORKING ON HOW WE
CAN ADVANCE AND INNOVATE MEDIC
CAL AS WELL AS HOW TO INVEST IN
THE YOUTH MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS.
IT WILL BE NECESSARY TO
TRANSFORM AND FUNDAMENTALLY
CHANGE THE SYSTEMS FOR THE
BETTER AND IT IS AN HONOR TO BE
A PART OF THE PROCESS AS WE
WILL MOVE CAL AIM AND THE
CHILDREN AND YOUTH BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH INITIATIVE. IN ADDITION
TO THE INSPIRING LEADERSHIP PUT
FORWARD BY THIS ADMINISTRATION.
MY HOPE IS THAT WE CAN MAKE
GREAT STRIDES THIS YEAR AND ALL
OF THE FOLLOWING. FIRST
HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE NOT JUST
ON BEHAVIORAL HEALTH BUT ALSO
ON SKILLED NURSING CARE AND
HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE
DIVERSITY. SECOND INCREASING
AVAILABILITY TO HEALTH SERVICES
BY PROVIDING EVERY POSSIBLE
METHOD OF ACCESSING HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS HI E. TELEHEALTH
WHICH WAS PROVEN DURING THIS
PANDEMIC. TO IMPROVE EQUITY AND
ACCESS. THIRD KEY PUBLIC HEALTH
INVESTMENTS INCLUDING ENDING
THE EPIDEMICS OF HIV SEXUALLY
TRANSMITTED INFECTIONS AND
HEPATITIS ALE LESS CARE
REDUCING DISPARITIES IN
CHILDREN'S MENTAL AND PHYSICAL
HEALTH AND OF COURSE INFECTIOUS
DISEASE CONTROL. FOURTH ON
YOUTH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH THE
GOVERNOR'S INITIATIVE PROVIDES
AN UNPRECEDENTED OPPORTUNITY TO
BUILD A WORLD CLASS ONE OF A
KIND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM FOR KIDS. CALIFORNIA
MUST ALSO ACT NOW WITH GREAT
URGENCY TO ENSURE THAT KIDS
HAVE THE SUPPORTS THEY NEED
THIS YEAR IN ORDER TO
SUCCESSFULLY TRANSITION BACK TO
SCHOOL AND RECOVER FROM THE
TRAUMA OF THIS PANDEMIC. THERE
ARE MANY INVESTMENTS UNDER
CONSIDERATION AND HUMAN
SERVICES INCLUDING THOSE THAT
SUPPORT CHILDREN SERVED IN OUR
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM WHO HAVE
EXPERIENCED MULTIPLE AND DEEP
TRAUMA. WE ARE LOOKING AT WAYS
TO ADDITIONALLY SUPPORT OUR
SENIORS PERSONS SERVED IN OUR
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES SYSTEM
AND OUR IMMIGRANT BROTHERS AND
SISTERS. FINALLY WE WANT TO
MODERNIZE OUR CAL WORKS PROGRAM
THAT SERVES OUR POOREST
FAMILIES WITH CHILDREN LIVING
BELOW 50% OF THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LINE KNOWN AS DEEP
POVERTY. WE WANT TO MAKE THIS
PROGRAM MORE EMPATHETIC AND
HELPFUL AT THIS TIME OF GREAT
ECONOMIC STRUGGLE FOR SO MANY.
LET'S MAKE SURE THAT IT AND
EVERY SOCIAL SERVICE PROGRAM IS
OPTIMALLY PREPARED TO HELP
ALLEVIATE POVERTY AND GIVE
EVERY PERSON BASIC SUPPORTS AND
ULTIMATELY AN OPPORTUNITY TO
BREAK THE CYCLE OF POVERTY
WHICH IS SO INGRAINED AND CAST
ALONG RACIAL LINES IN OUR STATE.
THERE ARE MANY WAYS THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO IMPROVE THIS
PROGRAM AND I AM COMMITTED TO
GETTING US THERE. I WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUES FOR THEIR
INDULGENCE AND ACCEPTANCE OF
THE COUNTLESS HOURS THE LONG
HEARINGS AND FOR ALLOWING OUR
COMMITTEE TO BE WHERE THE
PEOPLE ARE HEARD. I ESPECIALLY
WANT TO THANK THE PUBLIC FOR
THEIR PARTICIPATION TO MAKE
THIS BUDGET REFLECT ALL
CALIFORNIANS AND THEIR
PRIORITIES. AND TO TRULY MAKE
THIS THE PEOPLE'S HOUSE. WITH
THAT WE WILL NOW GO TO THE PULP
PHONE LINE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
WE HAVE A SUBSTANTIAL NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT AND
THEREFORE I WANT TO URGE YOU TO
KEEP YOUR COMMENTS BRIEF. SO
THAT WE CAN HEAR FROM EVERYONE.
AS A REMINDER THE PHONE NUMBER
TO CONNECT IS ON THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AND SHOULD B ON THE
SCREEN IF YOU ARE WATCHING OVER
THE INTERNET. THE NUMBER AGAIN
IS. 1-877-692-8957 THE PUBLIC
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN. I WILL
BEFORE WE BEGIN OPERATOR I'D
LIKE TO. OPEN THE ROLE IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. FOR PART A AND
PART B. OF THE AGENDA. CAN WE
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE FOR PART
AA ISSUES ONE. THREE SEVENTY
SIX ACCUSED ME ISSUES ONE
THROUGH NINETY EIGHT. YES THANK
YOU SHOULD JUST GO FROM.
ASSEMBLY IT JUST TOOK FIRST
SECOND THIRD FOURTH. THAT UP
FOR THE SAKE OF NOT REPEATING
OURSELVES I'D LIKE TO REPEAT
THE BATCHES THAT WE ORIGINALLY
DID IF WE COULD TAKE A VOTE ON
THE FIRST BATCH OF PART A FOR
ANY ABSENT MEMBERS. RUBIO HI.
CAN WE NOW CALL FOR THE SECOND
BATCH UNDER PART A- RUBIO HI
CAN WE CALL FOR THE THIRD BATCH
UNDER PART A RUBIO HI. AND
FINALLY FOR THE FOURTH BATCH ON
PART. RUBIO HI. WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO PART B. CAN WE CALL THE
ROLL ON THE FIRST BATCH. RUBIO
HI. HAS HAD. SEVEN THANK YOU
CAN WE OPEN UP ON THE SECOND
BATCH PLEASE RUBIO HAS FIVE.
CAN WE OPEN UP ON THE THIRD
BATCH PLEASE RUBIO I HAVE
SEVEN. THANK YOU BEFORE WE OPEN
IT TO PUBLIC COMMENT I'D LIKE
TO OFFER AN OPPORTUNITY TO ANY
OTHER MEMBERS WHO ARE ON THIS
COMMITTEE WHO MAY WANT TO MAKE
ANY COMMENTS OR STATEMENTS THAT
THEY HAVE. WE WILL BEGIN WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRAZIER
FOLLOWED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MATHIS. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR-
JUST WANTED TO ITEMS AND I KNOW
I SOUND LIKE A BROKEN RECORD TO
MY COLLEAGUES BUT- AGAIN ONE OF
THE THINGS IS JUST ABSOLUTELY.
COMPLETELY BAFFLES ME IS WHEN
WE REQUEST RATE STUDY TO BE
COMPLETED FOR THE IDT
POPULATION. AND IT DOES GET
COMPLETED AT A COST OF THREE
MILLION DOLLARS AND THEN IT
COMES OUT THREE YEARS AGO. AND
WE STILL HAVEN'T IMPLEMENTED.
DID WE WANT TO RAISE STUDY DID
WE WANT TO KNOW WHAT OUR
DEFICIENCIES WERE TO SUPPORT
THIS PROP- POPULATION- YOU KNOW
HERE WE ARE IN A BUDGET SURPLUS
AND WE'VE MADE THESE PROMISES
EURO AFTER YEAR AFTER YEAR TO
THIS POPULATION. AND THEY
DESERVE BETTER THAN THAT AND
YEAH YEAH IS A QUOTE FROM YOU
IS THIS ALIGNMENT STATE OR
WHAT. DO WE ACTUALLY FOLLOW.
WALK THE WALK AND TALK THE TALK
FOR THESE FOLKS- AND AGAIN I'M
HOPING THAT WE CAN ADDRESS
THIS. IF NOT HILL BY YOU A
BUDGET BABY BILL AND IN AUGUST
TO A KNOWLEDGE OF. THIS NEEDS
TO HAPPEN NEEDS TO STOP AND
HAPPEN NARAL OF THESE FOLKS ARE
A PRIORITY THERE PRIORITY TO
ALL OF US. SECOND ONE IS I WAS
JUST MADE AWARE YESTERDAY AND I
APOLOGIZE FOR THE LATE NOTICE
THE STATE HOSPITALS HAS MADE MY
COUNTY. AND SACRAMENTO COUNTY-
SUBJECT TO. OF RECEIVING UP TO
TEN THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED
MENTAL PATIENTS THROUGH THE
CALENDAR. AND THEY'RE GONNA
STOP OF SUPPLYING THE MONEY TO
KAISER TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
THE SERVICES. BY TONY IS NOT
PREPARED FOR THIS AMOUNT OF
ADDITIONAL MENTAL HEALTH
PATIENTS. THIS IS REMINISCENT
OF THE REAGAN ERA. THIS IS
ALMOST WHAT WE DID TO THE
DISABLED- ID POPULATION WITH
THE DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS. WERE
WERE GETTING RID OF SERVICES
AND WERE A- KNOWLEDGE AND
MAKING LOCAL JURISDICTIONS. A
TAKE ON A LOOK OF GOOD THAT DID
WITH THE EIGHTIES WITH MENTAL
HEALTH OF THE HOMELESS. CRISIS
WE HAVE NOW UNDERGOING
EXACERBATE THAT IN THESE TWO
COUNTIES WHICH ARE ALREADY.
GONE SO I'M HOPING THROUGH THE
CHAIR AND THIS COMMITTEE THAT
WE CAN ADDRESS THIS CALLIN
ISSUE WITH. A SLOW CARRY
SACRAMENTO COUNTY- BECAUSE
AGAIN- YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT A
CRISIS THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MATHIS FOLLOWED BY SOME
REMEMBER. GREAT MINDS THINK
ALIKE MISTER FRAZIER- WITH IT
WITH THE- YOUR LAST POINT I
DON'T THINK IT'S JUST THOSE TWO
COUNTIES I THINK WE DEFINITELY
NEED TO LOOK AT WHAT THAT'S
GOING TO AFFECT STATE WIDE- TO
ENSURE WE DON'T HAVE THAT
TRAVESTY AGAIN. I'D ALSO LIKE
TO ECHO THE POINTS- FOR RDT
COMMUNITY- AS MR FRAZIER
ALREADY SAID BUT- YEAH WE
DIDN'T. VOTE ON THIS ISSUE
RIGHT NOW IT WASN'T ON OUR
AGENDA TODAY AND WE ALL KNOW
IT'S A HIGH PRIORITY. SO TO
GOING DEEPER I'M TALKING ABOUT
THE MONEY THAT THE TWENTY
NINETEEN. PROVIDER RATE STUDY
SHOWS IS NEEDED. IN TWENTY
NINETEEN DDS ISSUED A STUDY
THAT ESTIMATED SERVICE
PROVIDERS WERE. UNDERFUNDED BY
ONE POINT EIGHT BILLION EVERY
YEAR THE CAN TO MY COLLEAGUE
MISTER FREIGHTERS POINT WE ARE
IN A HUGE BUDGET SURPLUS. THE
TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET THEN
PROVIDED LESS THAN 25% OF THE
AT AMOUNT. NOW THE GAP IS
AROUND EIGHT HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION THE GENERAL FUND. ONE
POINT FOUR BILLION WITH FEDERAL
FUNDS THAT IS THE AMOUNT NEEDED
TO ENSURE THAT PEOPLE WITH
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES A QUALITY SERVICES
IN PLACE TO HELP THEM LIVE
INDEPENDENTLY. IT IS DIFFICULT
TO UNDERSTAND HOW. THE MAY
REVISION HAS NO PROPOSAL TO
FUND THE RATE IT'S THAT THE
STUDY SHOWS ARE NEEDED. THE
GOVERNOR'S TALK ABOUT HOW HIS
HISTORIC THIS BUDGET IS AS WE
JUST TALKED ABOUT IN THE
OPENING. HOWEVER WHAT WOULD. BE
TRULY HISTORIC. IS IF WE
FINALLY STOPPED SHORT CHANGING
SERVICES TOWARD THE COMMUNITY.
I'M SURE THAT MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES ACROSS THE AISLE
SHARE MY CONCERNS SUCH AS MY
DEAR COLLEAGUE MISTER FRAZIER.
THIS IS A COMMUNITY THAT WE ALL
WANT TO HELP. RELEASED WE SAY
WE WANT TO HELP. I'D BE
PREPARED TO VOTE TODAY THE FUN
THE ENTIRE RATE STUDY. BUT I'M
HOPING WE CAN FIND IN AGREEMENT
WITH ALL MEMBERS SO I HOPE WE
CAN KEEP TALKING ABOUT THIS IN
THE NEXT FEW DAYS AND THEN
APPROVED THE RATE INCREASES
NEXT WEEK AT OUR FULL BUDGET
COMMITTEE HEARING MR FRAZIER I
DO RESPECT THE POINT ABOUT A
TRAILER BILL FOR AUGUST BUT I
THINK. IS DIRE IS THIS ISSUE IS
THE FACT THAT WE ALL HAVE ALL
BEEN DISCUSSING THIS FOR OVER
SEVEN YEARS ON IT WE PUSH TO
GET THE STUDY WE GOT THE STUDY
WE KNOW WHAT THE STUDY SAYS. IT
AGAIN TO QUOTE GERMAN ARAMBULA
ARE WE ALIGNMENT STATE OR NOT
MEMBERS. I REST MY CASE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALMOST THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THIS ONE-
SAY SOME BRIEF COMMENTS AND ALL
COMMENTS LEADING UP TO- THE
NEXT MEETING WITH A FULL
BUDGET- COMMITTEE CERTAINLY
SEEN- THE MENTAL HEALTH AND THE
YOUTH COMPONENT BEING PART OF
WHAT THE MINISTRATION WITH HIS
BODY DISCUSSES IS REALLY
SOMETHING THAT'S OVER DUE TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR YOUTH I HAVE
THE MENTAL RESOURCES THAT THEY
NEED AND PUTTING THE
STAKEHOLDERS TOGETHER THAT WE
WOULD INCLUDE. THE EDUCATION-
ARENA AS WELL AS PARENTS AND
OTHERS THAT ARE THERE THAT ARE
THE FIRST LINE OF DEFENSE WITH
OUR YOUTH THAT COULD BE
SUFFERING ARE ARE SUFFERING.
WITH GREAT NEEDS SOME FOR
MENTAL HEALTH AND RESOURCES
THAT ARE THERE AND ALSO JUST
WANT TO CONTINUE TO PUSH ON THE
OFFICE OF SUICIDE PREVENTION IN
THE FUNDING FOR THE RESOURCES
THAT ARE THERE WE HEARD IT-
DISCUSS WITH MANY PANELISTS
THAT CAME UP BEFORE THIS- THIS
BODY THAT TALKED ABOUT IT AN
AREA WHERE ALL THESE RESOURCES
CAN BE FUNNELED TO SO THEN
WE'RE NOT PULLING FROM
DIFFERENT AREAS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE THAT THERE IS A- AN AREA.
THAT WE CAN GET ALL THESE
RESOURCES TO IMPORT FROM THAT
DATA AND I BELIEVE THAT THE
OFFICE OF SUICIDE PREVENTION IS
ESTABLISHED TO BE ABLE TO DO
THAT- THE FUNDING COMPONENT OF
IT WE TALKED ABOUT HERE- IT'S
GREAT TO SEE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS SEEN THE
MERITS OF THAT BUT I WOULD
ALSO- CONTINUE TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE AN OPEN MIND WITH MY
COLLEAGUES AS WE GO INTO THE
NEXT DISCUSSION WITH A FULL
BUDGET- COMMITTEE ITSELF. SO
IT'S- SOMETHING THIS IS
DRASTICALLY NEEDED TO CONTINUE
TO TALK ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH AND
THE RESOURCES ARE THERE BECAUSE
NOW MORE THAN EVER WE'RE SEEING
THE IMPACT NOT ONLY JUST ON THE
WHOLE POPULATION BUT SEVERELY
ON OUR YOUTH POPULATION IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SOMEONE
THANK YOU FOR. ALLOWING US TO
BRING THOSE ISSUES UP AND FOR
THE SOMEBODY TO TAKE THOSE-
INTO CONSIDERATION AND MOVING.
FORWARD WITH THE ADVOCACY OF
THOSE ISSUES. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WAS. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- I REALLY
APPRECIATE- THE CONVERSATION
AND I WON'T- BELIEVER THE POINT
BECAUSE I THINK THIS COMMITTEE
HAS BEEN- AND AN AGREEMENT THIS
WHOLE ENTIRE TIME ABOUT WHAT
THE PRIORITIES ARE AND BUT I
WOULD LIKE TO SAY THAT- YOU
KNOW WHERE I AN UNPRECEDENTED
TIMES THAT'S OUR FAVORITE WORD-
AND WE HAVE MONEY THAT- WAS
NOT- PROJECTED. UP BY MY
OPINION ON AND I'VE SAID THIS
BEFORE- THIS MONEY IS NOT
EXTRA- THERE'S MANY PROGRAMS
ESPECIALLY AND HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES THAT HAVE BEEN CUT
THERE WERE CUT IN TWO THOUSAND
AND EIGHT. WHEN WE WENT TO OUR
OUR BUDGET CRISIS THOSE
PROGRAMS HAVE NOT A LOT OF THEM
HAVE NOT BE REINSTATED BEEN
REINSTATED WE CANNOT SAY IT'S
EXTRA MONEY UNTIL WE AKE ALL
OF THOSE PROGRAMS HOLE- IT'S A-
REWARDING TO BE HERE BUT IT'S
ALSO FRUSTRATING BECAUSE WE
KEEP FIGHTING OVER THINGS THAT
SHOULD HAVE BEEN. EITHER
REINSTATED OR HAVE BEEN
IMPLEMENTED BUT TO THAT I WANT
TO THANK MY- COLLEAGUES ON THIS
COMMITTEE ESPECIALLY YOU MISTER
CHAIR. I KNOW HOW DIFFICULT IT
IS AND HOW LONG HOURS I. YOU'VE
SPENT BEING IN THIS COMMITTEE
BUT SOMETIMES BY YOURSELF I
WANTED TO- ACKNOWLEDGE AND
APPRECIATE YOU FOR A FOR YOUR
YOUR OUR PERSEVERANCE THROUGH
ALL OF THIS IT'S BEEN. AMAZING
TO WATCH THE DEDICATION THAT
YOU HAVE DEMONSTRATED- IT
WITHIN THIS COMMITTEE. FOR
THOSE OF RIGHT FOR THE RIGHT
REASONS FOR THOSE PEOPLE THAT
WE'RE ALL FIGHTING FOR AND SO I
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE YOU AND
APPRECIATE THAT THE LONG HOURS.
BUT ALSO THAT THE THAT MY
COMMITTEE- MEMBERS ITS IT'S-
AMAZING TO BE IN THE COMMITTEE
WHERE WE DON'T ALWAYS AGREE-
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO- FIFTEEN
AT PROGRAMS FOR FOLKS THAT- THE
MORE MOBILE FOLKS- THAT WE ALL
CAN COME TOGETHER AND FIGHT FOR
THOSE REASONS ALL. THANK YOU
BYE ARE MOVING ON TO THE NEXT
PHASE OF THE BUDGET WE STILL
CONTENT NEED TO CONTINUE TO
FIGHT FOR THOSE PRIORITIES THAT
WE OUTLINED IN THE BEGINNING. A
BUDGET IS NOT- EXTRA MONEY IF
THE PROGRAMS THAT WE CUT HAVE
NOT BEING REINSTATED IN A LOT
OF THE PROGRAMS THAT HAVE BEEN
CUT AND HAVE NOT BEEN
REINSTATED IN THIS COMMITTEE-
ARE THOSE. BAD REALLY SUPPORT
BILLS POPULATION THAT WERE ALL
FIGHTING FOR SO I WANT TO THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND THANK THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
THEIR- SUPPORT OF EACH OTHER IN
SUPPORT OF OUR ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES. I'M FROM SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA BUT I FIND MYSELF
FIGHTING FOR CENTRAL AND
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. AND VICE
VERSA AND I APPRECIATE THAT
BECAUSE I DO REPRESENT THE
FOURTEENTH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY WE
REPRESENT CALIFORNIA AND ALL F
THE DECISIONS I MEAN WE MAKE
HERE. HELP THE FOLKS IN
CALIFORNIA UP AND DOWN THE
STATE'S UP THANK YOU. OKAY
SEEING AS THAT IS THE
CONCLUSION OF MEMBERS COMMENTS
I WOULD NOW LIKE TO HAVE THE
OPERATOR GETS READY TO BEGIN
PUBLIC COMMENT I WILL REMIND
THE PUBLIC AGAIN THE PHONE
NUMBER SHOULD BE UP ON THE
WEBSITE AT THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AND SHOULD BE ON THE
SCREEN IF YOU ARE WATCHING OVER
THE INTERNET THE NUMBER IS.
1-877-692-8957 THE PUBLIC
ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN. OPERATOR
WE ARE READY TO BEGIN PUBLIC
COMMENT. THESE- ISSUES PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR WILL GIVE
YOUR LINE NUMBER OFFLINE THE
PLACE YOU BACK IN THE QUEUE
AGAIN FOR A PUBLIC COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. YOU KNOW OUR FIRST ARTIST
BUT WILL BE ONE THIRTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO CHAIR AND
MEMBERS DISMISSED HER AGAIN BY
EASTMAN REPRESENTING THAT'S
FINE BURKE AND IF YOU WERE AN
INDEPENDENT NONPROFIT PUBLIC
POLICY INSTITUTE WHO SPOKE AT
THE TO DANCE SOUND PUBLIC
POLICY AND INSPIRED LEADERSHIP
ON THE ISSUE THE BRAIN HEALTH.
I'D LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR Q. ISSUES ON
TODAY'S AGENDA THAT ARE BEING
HELD UP BY AN- AGENDA EIGHT IF
YOU WANT THE CHILDREN. AND
YOUTH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INITIATIVE. ASSEMBLY HEART BY
THE- CAN. TO PROP. AND
DEEPENING OUR CARE FOR OUR
CHILDREN BE AND YOUNG ADULTS.
WERE PARTICULARLY APPRECIATIVE
OF THE INVESTMENT TO EXPAND OUR
WORK FORCE. AGENDA BE ISSUE
TWENTY SEVEN THE COMMUNITY CARE
EXPANSION- WE WOULD ALSO URGE
THE COMMITTEE TO ALLOW THE
FUNDS TO BE USED NOT ONLY FOR
ACQUISITION AND REHABILITATION
BUT ALSO INCREASE MONTHLY
PAYMENTS SUPPORTING CARE
OPERATORS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MA'AM NEXT CALLER PLEASE. FIVE
FORTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS RONALD
KOEMAN CAME ON BEHALF OF STREET
AND THE CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC
HEALTH NETWORK BURKE I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK DR ARAMBULA
AFFIRMATIVE IMMENSE BODY OF
WORK AND LEADERSHIP ON HEALTH
EQUITY WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
A BUDGET THAT WILL TAKE BOLD
ACTION ACTION TO DISRUPT AND
BREAK DOWN SYSTEMIC RACISM IN
OUR HEALTHCARE SYSTEM WE NEED
ALL CALIFORNIANS COULD DRIVE IN
PROGRAMS AND OTHER INVESTMENTS
THAT ENSURE WE FINALLY TREAT
RACISM OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS ARE LONG OVERDUE. WELL
WE NEED A STRONG INFRASTRUCTURE
AND WORKFORCE WE NEED
INVESTMENTS THAT ALLOW US TO
FOCUS ON RACIAL EQUITY SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH AND
PREVENTION AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR THAT CONTINUE TO BE
PLAGUED BY HEALTH DISPARITIES
ADDITIONALLY WE APPLAUD THE
GOVERNOR NEWSOMFOR PROPOSING
TO EXPAND MEDICAID OUT TO
SENIORS AGE SIXTY PLUS
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS WE ARE RELATED TO SEE
THAT ASSEMBLY AND SENATE. ARE
PROPOSING TO GO MUCH FURTHER TO
EXPAND MEDICARE TO UNDOCUMENTED
INDIVIDUALS FIFTEEN UP WELL
THIS IS A STEP FORWARD WE MUST
MAKE SURE IMPLEMENTATION
HAPPENS QUICKLY AND WE MUST
ALSO PRIORITIZE EXPANDING
HEALTH COVERAGE TO ALL ADULTS
WHICH DOCTOR REGULARS AB. FOUR
SIX TO DO BY TWENTY TWENTY SIX.
THANK YOU. THANK OU SIR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. FORTY NINE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON DIANA
DOUGLAS BUT HELD BACK THE
CALIFORNIA WOULD COMMENT ON
SEVERAL ISSUES FOR IF YOU'RE
TWELVE RELATED TO DAMAGE THE
EQUITY MEASURES WE SUPPORTED
DOCKING THE PLACEHOLDER TBL AS
WE ARE ENGAGING IN
CONVERSATIONS THAT APARTMENT TO
ENSURE THAT THE MEASURES WILL
BE ROUTINELY UPDATED ONCE
DETERMINED AND IF YOU THIRTY
TWO WITH THE POSITIVE NEWS
ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA BUDGET
SURPLUS. WE SUPPORT INCLUDING
AS MANY UNDOCUMENTED PEOPLE IF
POSSIBLE AND MEDIKAL THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS FOR INCLUDING
OUR COMMUNITY MEMBERS FIFTY AND
OLDER IN THIS PROPOSAL WE
APPRECIATE THAT FOR A HUGE
NINETY SIX NINETY SEVEN RELATED
TO COVER CALIFORNIA WE AGAIN
URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
CONTINUE OUR COMMITMENT TO
AFFORDABILITY FACTORS DURING
THE EXISTING SEVEN HUNDRED
MILLION AND STATE SUBSIDIES IN
THE RESERVE FUND. THE
INDIVIDUAL MANDATE PENALTY
REVENUE ALONE IS NOT SUFFICIENT
TO MAINTAIN OUR STATE SUBSIDY
PROGRAM IF THE FEDERAL
SUBSIDIES EXPIRE WE ALSO ASK
THAT COVER CALIFORNIA BE
DIRECTED TO RECONFIGURE AND
IMPLEMENT REDUCE DEDUCTIBLES
AND COST SHARING FOR TWENTY
TWENTY THREE AND FINALLY WE ARE
IN SUPPORT OF ISSUE NINETY
EIGHT RELATED TO THE ONE DOLLAR
PREMIUM SUBSIDIES AND
APPRECIATE IT THANK WHICH AND
TO GET MORE COVERED CALIFORNIA
ENROLLEES DOWN TO TRUE. ZERO
PREMIUM PLANS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
FIFTY ONE PLEASE CALL. YES I'D
LIKE TO THINK THE CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND STAFF FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY I AM CHRIS
BURNS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
BOYS AND GIRLS REPUBLICANS
SERVING HUNDREDS OF THIS YEAR
TO TWO YEARS FROM A DOZEN
OUNTIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE I
WANT TO ECHO THE PREVIOUS
ADVOCACY FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ALMOST RECOMMENDING THE CODE
RELIEF PACKAGE FIRST YEAR KEEP
GETTING. YOUR KIDNEYS ARE THE
ICO OBSCURE CONTINUUM PROVIDING
CRITICAL THERAPEUTIC
INTERVENTION FOR FOSTER YOUTH
NEEDING THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF
CARE THAT ADDRESSES THEIR
TRAUMA AND MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS
IN A TEMPORARY RESIDENTIAL
SETTING MUCH LIKE ICU NURSES
AND DOCTORS DURING THIS
PANDEMIC USED NEEDS ARE
EXTRAORDINARY AND HINGED UPON
THE UNWAVERING COMMITMENT OF
THIS CHURCH THE STAFF COMING TO
WORK EACH DAY. IN FEAR FOR
THEIR OWN HEALTH TO PROVIDE THE
CARE NECESSARY TO ASSIST THESE
TRAUMATIZED STUDENTS THAT DAILY
COMMITMENT CAME AT TREMENDOUS
FINANCIAL EXPENSE THAT POSES A
THREAT TO OUR OPERATIONS WHEN
TREATMENT NEEDS FOR ADDED STATE
USE THAN THOSE TRANSITIONING
FROM DJJ ARE INCREASING THE
NEED FOR HIGH QUALITY EST TV
PLACEMENTS. THIS IS BEEN AN
INCREDIBLY CHALLENGING YOUR
ATTENTION THESE SERVICES BUT
THEY WERE DELIVER CONTINUOUS
AND IN PERSON TO SUPPORT THE
HEALING OF TISSUES AND FAMILIES
DESPITE THE OVERWHELMING **** I
THANK YOU CAN REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT THE FORTY TWO MILLION
ONE TIME FUNDING CREST HERE TO
BE COVERED RELATING TO ENSURE
THE ONGOING STABILITY HEALTH
AND SAFETY YEARS FAMILIES AND
STAFF THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SIR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK SO YOU ARE ON.
THANK YOU MISTER AND MEMBER.
BARENAKED I'LL BE HAPPY CAL
STATE ASSOCIATION COUNTIES I
WILL LIMIT MY COMMENTS ONLY ADD
IN ON WHICH YOU VOTED WILL. ON
ITEMS THREE THE MANAGER CARE
PER RECREATION- APPROVED THE
COMMITTEE APPROVING THAT AND
WHILE LAW BOB NEEDS TO GO HOW
WORLD OUT WE'RE REALLY THAT THE
POP. ON ITEM NUMBER FORTY FOUR
FUNDING FOR OUR PUBLIC
HOSPITALS WERE STRUGGLING WITH
THE FUNDING GAP DUE TO COLDER
TREATING MORE COMPETITION WE
TRULY APPRECIATE YOUR VOTING-
TO. MOVE THAT FORWARD IN THE
BUDGET PROCESS WE'RE VERY
THANKFUL LASTLY ON ITEM SEVENTY
ONE UNDER THE DEPARTMENT STATE
HOSPITAL- WE APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE VOTED TO APPROVE THE
WITHDRAWAL OF THE JANUARY I. S.
G. COMMUNITY PARTNERSHIP
PROGRAM PUT FORTH BY DSHS
HOWEVER- WE ARE IN CURRENT
TALKS WITH THE ESTATES AND
ADMINISTRATION- POTENTIALLY
OTHER. SOLUTIONS BOB PSH IS
ALSO A BILL PROPOSING TO STOP
ACCEPTING LPS CONSERVATORSHIP
PATIENTS FROM COUNTIES HAD
DEFENDED MANY CONSERVATIVE BACK
TO COUNTIES AT A TIME WHEN WE
DO NOT HAVE THE WALK OR
PLACEMENTS FOR THESE FOLKS
WE'RE THAT- EARNED. WITH ALL OF
THESE PROPOSALS ARE TEN BUT WE
WILL CONTINUE. TO SEE IF THE
POLLUTION CAN BE RE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT CALL
PLEASE. OPERATOR FIFTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU DR
ARAMBULA AND MEMBERS ENGAGED
YET ON BEHALF OF AND YEAH YOU
CALIFORNIA BURKE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT ON THE HELP FOR
ALL SENIOR MEDICAID EXPANSION
AND EXTENDING IT TO DEAL WITH
FIFTY YEARS OLD AND HAVE A-
SECOND WE ALSO THANK YOU FOR
PROVING THAT THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR PUBLIC HOSPITAL
SYSTEM. BUDGET REQUIRE BUDGET-
NAY REVISED PROPOSAL WHICH
WOULD OFFSET THE COST OF
TREATING KOBE NINETEEN PATIENTS
WHO NEED IT I SEE YOU AND
HOSPITAL HOSPITAL SERVICES-
THANK YOU DOC RANDALL AND-
WOULD YOUR CAN. LEADERSHIP ON
ENSURING OUR LOCAL PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS ARE FINALLY
WE INVESTED IN BY INCLUDING
AUGMENTATION FOR YOU FUNDING
AND THE PLACEHOLDER TVL. AND
LASTLY WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU ON SHAPING ALL
OF THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE
PROPOSAL. ESPECIALLY THE
CHILDREN AND YOUTH INITIATIVES
IN THE NEXT FEW DAYS. IT'S
HISTORIC INVESTMENT OF OVER
FOUR BILLION DOLLARS IN
TRANSFORMING CALIFORNIA.
APPROACH THE CHILDREN
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH IS A ONCE IN
A. GENERATION OPPORTUNITY THAT
CANNOT BE SQUANDERED.
CALIFORNIA MUST LOOK TO THE
EXPERTISE OF OUR PUBLIC SECTOR
WHICH CONTINUES TO BE LEFT OUT
WITHOUT THE RESOURCES. NEEDED
TO PROVIDE THE CRUCIAL SERVICES
SO MANY KIDS REQUIRE. OUR
PUBLIC SECTOR WORKFORCE MUST BE
AT THE FOREFRONT OF SHAPING THE
DELIVERY OF THE SERVICES.
ENSURING ACCOUNTABILITY AND
OUTCOME FOR BILLIONS OF
TAXPAYER DOLLARS AND BUILDING
THAT THEY BIRTH WORKFORCE
NEEDED TO SERVE THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH NEEDS OF CALIFORNIANS.
FROM CHILDHOOD THROUGH
ADULTHOOD THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MA'AM. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. MY
SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MR CHAIR NUMBERS BUT I
THINK I CAN I WILL KEEP YOU
PUBLIC AFFAIRS FIRST TIME TO
HAVE THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF
FAMILY PHYSICIANS IN REGARD TO
GENDER PART EIGHTY ISSUE EIGHT
UNDER OSTAD. SHE THE COMMITTEE
DELIVER OF LOOK AT THE- CASTING
FORTY. OF TO ENSURE THE PRIMARY
CARE STATES FROM THE COUNTRY AS
WE ARE MATCHING PUBLIC HEALTH
PLANNING AND FORECASTING THE-
FUTURE. ALSO UNDER OUR STRATEGY
NINE ONE STRONG SUPPORT AT THE
FIFTY MILLION GOING TO FONG
BROWN'S RESIDENCY TRAINING
PROGRAM HAS PROPOSED AND THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR TAKING ACTION.
THE LAST THING ON THE HOPPNER
FAMILY PARTNERSHIP IN REGARDS
TO AGENDA EIGHT PART BIANCA CAL
WORKS GENERALLY. WE DO HOPE TO
SEE FUNDING AUGMENTED TRUCK
LIKE CAKE BUT POTENTIAL GROWTH
FOR THE CALVET FROM VISITING
PROGRAM. ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO
RIGHTLY STATED THAT WE NEED TO
RESTORE CUTS PARTICULARLY TO
PRISON PROGRAMS LIKE THE NURSE
FAMILY PARTNERSHIP. THE
EVIDENCE BASED HOME VISITING.
THE THIRTY MILLION DOLLAR CUT.
DURING LAST YEAR'S BUDGET NOT
TO CREATE PANDEMIC LEVELS. THE
PROVEN PROGRAM TO HELP FAMILIES
MOVE DEFAULT POSITION THINK
THIRTY CONTROL INFANT HEALTH
DISPARITIES. LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH DIGNITY MOVEMENT
FORWARD THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MA'AM. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
FIFTY FOUR PLEASE CALL. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS TEN WHEN FROM
CLASS ADVISE ON BEHALF OF LIVER
DENTAL. ON ITEM NUMBER FORTY
TWO WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE
PROPOSED ELIMINATION OF DENTAL
MANAGED CARE IN SACRAMENTO AND
LOS ANGELES COUNTIES THREE
QUICK COMMENTS ONE IS REGARDING
THE ACCUSATION THAT SOMEHOW
UTILIZATION LAGS IN SACRAMENTO
COUNTY IN LOS ANGELES AS
COMPARED TO FEE FOR SERVICE
COUNTIES I JUST LIKE TO REMIND
THE COMMITTEE THAT THE DATASETS
COMPARING THE TWO PROGRAMS ARE
NOT THE SAME OF PAPER SERVICE
USES DIFFERENT INPUTS THAT
MANAGED CARE PROGRAM SO
UTILIZATION AS A METRIC- IS
MISLEADING AND WHEN YOU COMPARE
LIKE DATASETS I MANAGED CARE
OUTPERFORM CHEAPER SERVICE.
SECONDLY I'D LIKE TO COMMENT
ON- SOMETHING THAT THE
DEPARTMENT HAS SAID RELATIVE TO
THE PROVIDER NETWORKS ANOTHER
SIGNIFICANT OVERLAP BETWEEN THE
FEE FOR SERVICE ENROLLMENT AND-
MANAGED CARE ROMAN SACRAMENTO
COUNTY THAT'S A MANDATE BY THE
DEPARTMENT BUT MANAGED CARE
PROVIDERS ARE ALSO ROLLED IN
PAPER SERVICE- YOU'VE HAD
TESTIMONY BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE
FROM PROVIDERS IN SACRAMENTO
COUNTY SAYING THEY WILL NOT
PARTICIPATE IF YOU FOR SERVICE
PROGRAM. WE RAN SOME OF THE
NUMBERS ONE OF THOSE PROVIDERS-
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR ALMOST 30%
OF THE GENERAL ANESTHESIA CARE
PROVIDED IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY
YOU WILL DISAPPEAR OVERNIGHT
AND ITS PRACTICE WILL AS WELL
LASTLY ADDITIONAL COMMUNITY
SUPPORT THAT WILL BE LOST
INCLUDING EARLY EARLY SMILES
SACRAMENTO PROGRAM INTEGRATED
CARE COORDINATION TARGETED
OUTREACH PROGRAMS. AND ON AND
ON AND ON SO WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THE ELIMINATION. THESE REASONS.
THANK YOU SIR. NEXT PLEASE.
FIFTY SIX YEAR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SURE MEMBERS KATHY MOST OF
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF YOUR
CLIENTS ON FOUR ISSUES BUT I
PROMISE I WILL BE BRIEF ON
FIRST ON BEHALF O A LOCAL
PRINTER CALIFORNIA WE CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSALS PERTAINING TO BETTY
CAL THE BIGGER VISION AND THE
LEADERSHIP OF THIS COMMITTEE
SPECIFICALLY THOSE PROPOSALS
THAT WILL EXTEND MEDICARE
ELIGIBILITY TO UNDOCUMENTED
ADULTS. LOCAL HEALTH PLAN STILL
HAVE SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT BOTH
THE USE THAT BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INITIATIVE AT THE KELLY
POPULATION HEALTH MANAGEMENT
PROPOSAL AND AT THE COMMITTEE
AND OTHERS HAVE REMARKS WE
BELIEVE MORE DETAILS ARE NEEDED
A BILL PROPOSALS INCLUDING HOW
THE WORLD LOOKS AT TO GATHER
AND THE ROLE THAT THE VISION
FOR MEDICAID MANAGED CARE PLAN
ON ITEM THIRTY FOUR THIRTY FIVE
ON BEHALF OF BOTH THE
INTERMEDIATE CARE FACILITIES
FOR THE DEVELOPMENT. TABLE
HOMES AND THE SCANDAL
PEDIATRICS PUBLIC UTILITIES WE
WISH TO THANK THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR REMOVING THE
LONG UNDERSTANDING RATE FREEZE
FOR THESE HOMES AND FACILITIES
AND WE CERTAINLY WANT TO THANK
MISSTEP COMMITTEE FOR THE
RECOMMENDATION TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO ENSURE
POST FOR YOU THE ARE I SEE UP
TO THE HOME HAVE SUFFICIENT
FUNDS TO CONTINUE PROVIDING
SERVICES TO THE VULNERABLE
INDIVIDUALS. ON ITEM THIRTY
NINE ON BEHALF OF THE FOOD
MEDICINE COALITION WE
APPRECIATE THE ADMINISTRATION
PRECLUDING ADDITIONAL DOLLARS
TO ALLOW US TO CONTINUE
PROVIDING MEDICALLY TAILORED
MEALS AND THIS COMMITTEE AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO
LEADERSHIP FOR SUPPORTING THAT
ACTION LASTLY ON ITEM TWENTY
NINE TELEHEALTH ON BEHALF OF
THE CONTRACTS OF HELP WANTED TO
PUT THIS COMMITTEE'S
RECOMMENDATION TO ABOUT PLACE
ORDER TRAILER BILL CONSISTENT
WITH AB THIRTY TWO AND OUT ALSO
ON BEHALF OF A CONTRACT WITH
HELP YOU CERTAINLY APPRECIATE
THE CHAIRS CALL OUT. OF THE IN
THE ACADEMIC ACADEMICS HOME
SOLUTIONS AND THOSE SOLUTIONS
THAT GO MORE WILL BE HEARD IN
FULL BUDGET TO DEAL WITH
APPROPRIATIONS FOR DEALING WITH
PREVENTION AND TESTING AND
TREATMENT TRUST YOU THESE- HIV
HAVE TO. THANK YOU FOR THOSE
COMMENTS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME THANK YOU MA'AM. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK SIXTIES
YOUR OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
ANDREA MIGUEL FROM PARENT
AFFILIATES CAL CALLING WITH A
COMMENT EACH YEAR ISSUE TWENTY
NINE I WANT TO RECOGNIZE LEVEL
OF THE THAT THE CHAIR AND
SEVERAL MEMBERS THE HAVE GIVEN
TO TELL PAUL CONVERSATIONS IN
THE MONTHS LEADING UP TO TODAY-
EQUITABLE COVERAGE OF
TELEHEALTH FOR MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES. AND ENSURING
ACCESS TO VARIOUS MODALITIES
IT'S SOMETHING THAT REALLY MUST
BE ADDRESSED BEFORE THE PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY HADN'T BEEN
FOR THE WORK DONE BY MEMBERS
AND STAFF HERE HAS BEEN
CRITICAL WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS
TODAY APPLE BUDGET TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE A LINE WITH ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTY TWO. I ALSO WANT TO
TAKE A MOMENT TO APPRECIATE THE
CHAIR'S COMMENTS ABOUT
INFECTION CONTROL AMONG KEY
ISSUES THAT STILL NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED IN CALIFORNIA'S FINAL
BUDGET ALONG THESE LINES WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT ADEQUATE
FUNDING FOR PROPER TORY
SERVICES PROVIDED A MEDIC CAL.
IT'S TIME TO FINALLY REPEAL.
THE POLICY FROM TWENTY TWELVE.
IT RECAP MEDICAL THAT THE
PERCENT OF MEDICARE- AMOUNT
THAT HAS BEEN A HARMFUL. TO
DRIVE DOWN THE AMOUNT OF
FUNDING AVAILABLE TO HEALTH
CENTERS ONE PROVIDING CORE
SERVICES SUCH AS A- TESTING.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
MA'AM NEXT CALLER PLEASE. SIX
WE WILL GO TO LINE SEVENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. A GOOD
AFTERNOON THE TEACHER MEMBERS
KATHY VAN OFTEN REPRESENTING
YOUR AT THE CENTER FOR POLICY
AND RESEARCH. I JUST WANTED TO
CALL AND- I JUST SAY HOW MUCH
WE APPRECIATE THAT SOMEONE
FRAZIER AND TO SOMEONE ABOUT
THAT COMMENTS REGARDING- THE
IDEA TO BREAK STUDY- YOU KNOW
IT'S BEEN A TREND TOWARD YEARS
NOW- WE UNDERSTAND EACH OTHER
COULD LAY. WITH THE PANDEMIC.
NOW REALLY IS THE MORE THAN A I
TO PUT THESE AND GETS RATES-
THE TURNOVER IS CUT HIGH.
FIGHTERS THEY TRAIN- THEY TRY
CARETAKERS. AND THEY GOT A 50%
TURNOVER RATE BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T KEEP THEM BECAUSE THE
RATES ARE LOW SHE AND WE'RE
DEALING WITH. HERE THAT IS KNOW
A DENTURE FACTORY UP- THAT SOME
WHAT VERY INTENSE NEEDS ALLEN
YOU THINK CANNOT- HEY PEOPLE-
THE YOU KNOW ADDRESS A LOT OF
WAYS TO PROVIDE THE LEVEL OF
CARE SO- I WOULD TO TRY THIS ON
THE TABLE AND- HOPEFULLY THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE. WILL TAKE
ANOTHER LOOK AT THE ARE THE
LEADER AND THE GOVERNOR OFFICE
WILL TAKE A LOOK AT BEST AT THE
CREDIT AND- ONE COMMON ON
BEHALF OF JOHN BURTON ADVOCATES
FOR YOU- WE DO A MEMBER TO
ABSENT HUNDRED TWO NINE DOLLARS
FOR- TRIED- TO YOU AND ON MY
DEPEND. UP FOR- PRENATAL
BENEFITS THE. THANK THANK YOU
MAY. X. COLOR. THANK YOU LANCE
SIX YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR MEMBERS CRACK ALSO
PER HALF OF A HELD A LOT
ANGELES AND THEN YOU KNOW PUT
THEM BACK STATE COLD. OR ONE
FIFTY COMMUNITY OR- JUST WANTED
TO THINK THAT YOU AND OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE YOUR
COMMENT AND SUPPORT EFFORTS
ADDRESS HEALTH. ASHLEY EFFORTS
TO ADDRESS EACH A. B. AT TI
HAVE. OVER THE- EPIDEMIC HAVE
BEEN NEGLECT FOR TOO LONG AND
IT'S TO GET A HAND ON THE
CRISES. THAT'S NOT NOW THAT
WORST PANDEMIC US SO THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR YOUR COMMENTS AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR SUPPORT
FOR THE AND THE ACADEMICS
REQUEST NEXT WEEK. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
WE'LL GO TO LINE SIXTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHEN MEMBERS ON THE BUT ALSO
THE WIDENING GROUP ON BEHALF
OF. BLUE SHIELD OF CALIFORNIA
AND AFTER YOU CALIFORNIA
PROVIDING COMMENT ON PART BE
SEVENTY EIGHT ON BEHALF OF OUR
CLIENT THE COMMANDER COMMITTEE
FOR HOLDING OPEN ITEM SEVENTY
EIGHT RELATED THE PROPOSAL TO
PROVIDE TWO POINT FIVE MILLION
TO BY THE HEALTH AND BENEFITS
IF THEY COULDN'T LOCAL. STAGE
THE PROPOSAL INCLUDES A THREE
YEAR STAKEHOLDER PROCESS BUT IN
ITEM THAT HAD REALLY BEEN
STUDIED FOR THE PROSPECT AND
DOESN'T EVEN CHARGE WITH THE
EQUAL TO ONE GROUP OF AN ACTION.
IN FACT LIVE HEALTH CALLS TO
INFORMATIONAL THE HEALTH
INFORMATION EXCHANGE EARLIER
THIS YEAR ACTUALLY EVERY ACTOR
INCLUDING FORMER DEPUTY
SECRETARY FOR HEALTH
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
INDICATED THAT FURTHER STUDY
ABOUT HEALTH INFORMATION
EXCHANGES NOT NECESSARY AND AT
THE TIME FOR ACTION WHILE. WE
WERE COMMENT ABOUT THE
LEGISLATURE MOVED EITHER
REJECTED TO SHORE NOT TO MONTH
BRAIN SPEC DRUGSTORE A CONCRETE
AND GOLD OF EVEN PLEASE RECORDS
AND WE CAN. MY NAME IS AND I'M
THE DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA.
COALITION AND I'D LIKE TO GET
RECOGNITION AGENT ITEM NUMBER.
THIRTY FIVE. OKAY REALLY
APPRECIATE. RUBIO AND OTHERS
HAVE I THINK ABOUT IT. THANK
YOU IMPORTANT. WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING. THANK YOU VERY.
NEXT WE WILL ALIGN SO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS GINA GOOD
HEALTH POLICY DIRECTOR FOR
CLEAN POWER ALLIANCE- WE ARE
THE COMMUNITY TRICK AGGREGATOR
REPRESENTING THREE MILLION
CUSTOMERS ACROSS LOS ANGELES
AND VENTURA COUNTIES AND THIRTY
THIRTY THE CONDUCT COUNTY. BUT
I WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND PACKAGE OF
ITEMS SEVENTY SIX THE AMERICAN
RAPPER AND ACTOR ENERGY ERICA
THIS YEAR- TWENTY EIGHT.
CUSTOMERS ACROSS SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA HAVE BEEN FACING
GROWING POWER TAXIS TO COVER
NINETEEN PANDEMIC BEGAN
ENROLLING OUT THAT BUDGET ITEM
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT IT
WOULD COMMENT THAT IN
CONJUNCTION WITH HTTP TO ENSURE
THAT PEOPLE RECEIVE THIS
DECORATIVE NOT AUTOMATICALLY
AND IF THEY DON'T YOU TO APPLY
FOR. AN APPLICATION PROCESS THE
ONLY SPOKEN DOWN AND WE NEED TO
GET THAT MONEY TO PEOPLE
IMMEDIATELY TO AVOID CUSTOMER
CREDIT IMPACTED THE CONNECTION.
I'M NOT GOING TO MAKE SURE THAT
LOW INCOME CUSTOMERS SUCH AS
THOSE THAT QUALIFY FOR CARE AND
THERAPY ARE PRIORITIZED BURKE
AND THEY'VE BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
THE CUP IN NINETEEN PENTOMIC
THANK YOU AGAIN. AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE. I YOU MA'AM. NEXT
CALL PLEASE. THANK FOUR YOU ARE
A- GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
ADRIN SO SOME OF THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES COMMENTING ON FOUR
ITEMS TODAY TO VOICE OUR
SUPPORT FIRST IS ITEM NUMBER
FIFTEEN. BOB HOPE SERVICES
ACCESSIBILITY ALSO ITEM THIRTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND PROFESSOR
THERE ARE A PART OF- ITEM
NUMBER FIFTY SIX WHICH IS THE
FUNDING FOR THE OFFICE OF BY
PROFESSION EXACTLY- SUPPORT
ITEM NUMBER NINETY VIEW THE
MENTAL HEALTH. SERVICES ACT. AS
IF THE CONCLUDE AS BOTH DOCTOR
ARE REGULAR AND THE PUBLIC
DOESN'T WANT US THE WEALTHY TO
THE BALLOT TODAY CALIFORNIANS
THAT'LL HELP YOU ONLY
INTENSIFIED DURING THE COPA
NINETY AND THAT MAKES IT IN
PARTICULAR FOR YEARS. SO WE
REALLY COULD NOT FILL OUT OUR
COMMUNITY BASED BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CARE THE NEW EVEN CREEK
NEEDS THAT WE BELIEVE THE
PROPOSAL THE FACT THAT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. SEVEN EIGHT YOU
ARE UP PLEASED AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY CARE NOW STATES
YOU LET ME SANTA ON BEHALF OF
AT YOU HELLO. ONE ECHO TO PRE.
FOR THE IN WORK YOU ALL OF
UNDERTAKEN TO ENSURE THAT THOSE
IN GREATEST NEED WILL HAVE THE
SAFETY NET PROTECTIONS TO CARRY
THEM THROUGH THE NEXT STAGE AS
WE MAKE OUR WAY OUT OF THE
PANDEMIC I'D LIKE TO EXPRESS
APPRECIATION FOR MAKING
REFERENCE TO THE ONGOING
CONCERN OF AN ITEM SIXTEEN AND
SEVENTEEN WERE GUARDING CREW UP
FOR THE FIRST FAMILY ASSISTANCE
AND WITHOUT THE LIKE. EXPRESS
APPRECIATION FOR SEVERAL OF THE
ITEMS THAT YOU HAVE CHOSEN TO
HOLD OPEN TO MAKE SURE THAT
ONGOING CONVERSATIONS AS IT
RELATES TO FAMILY FIRST
PREVENTION SERVICES ACT- CAL
WORKED AT SPECTRA- WILL HAVE
ONGOING CONVERSATIONS AND
REVIEW TO ENSURE THAT- COUNTY
AGENCIES AND THE WORKERS THAT-
PROVIDE SERVICES. TO THOSE MOST
pAPPROPRIATELY AND FINALLY WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS APPRECIATION
FOR- BE ITEMS AS THEY RELATE TO
IMMIGRANTS AT THE BORDER-
PARTICULARLY UNACCOMPANIED
MINORS AND- THE COUNTY'S
READING ABLE TO PROVIDE
ASSISTANCE TO THOSE ARRIVING AT
THE BORDER IN NEED OF
ASSISTANCE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MA'AM. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THAT'S WHY WILL GO TO
LINES NINE GOT. THAT AFTERNOON
THAT IS REBECCA OF THE
NATIONALIST OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER COMMENTING
ON A FEW ITEMS I THE NUMBER SIX
WE FULLY SUPPORT THE OFFICE OF
HEALTH CARE AFFORDABILITY AND-
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEES-
PROPOSAL TO AB PROVINCIALLY
APPROVED FUNDING AND THAT TREND
OF THE LANGUAGE TO MAKE THAT
OFTEN HAPPENS ALSO WANT TO
SUPPORT ITEM TWENTY NINE WHICH-
AND WE APPRECIATE THAT THE
COMMITTEE IS. REJECTING THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AND PUTTING
THAT THAT ACCOUNT TELEHEALTH
TELEHEALTH FLEXIBILITIES AND
LYING WITH AB THIRTY TWO- ALSO
I DO THIRTY CHIU EXPANSION OF
MEDICARE TO UNDOCUMENTED ADULTS
OVER FIFTY DEFINITELY
APPRECIATE GOING THAT EXTRA
STEP TO COVER. MORE PEOPLE IN
NEED- ALSO ITEM FIFTY SIX THE
SUPPORT OFFICE OF SUICIDE-
PREVENTION AND THEN LASTLY JUST
BRIEFLY WE ALSO WORK HOST
MONSTERS AND IF YOU REMEMBER
CLASS CALIFORNIA REDUCING
DISPARITIES PROJECT WE THINK-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARAMBULA FOR
HIS LEADERSHIP ON THAT ISSUE
AND HOPE AND- HOPE THAT GETS
FUNDED ALSO FOSTER FAMILY
AGENCY SOCIAL WORKERS HELPING.
MAKES MAKING SURE THAT THEY
HAVE ADEQUATE PAY SO WE DON'T
HAVE TURNOVER AND- THAT'S WHAT
YOUR KIDS HAVE WORSE OUTCOMES
WHEN THEIR SOCIAL WORKER ACTION
IS UNABLE TO KEEP THEIR JOBS-
AND ALSO AS AS I AT THE KEY WE
WANT TO DO- ADVOCATE THAT THE
GRANTS ARE RESTORED BACK TO THE
LEVELS THEY WORK. AND THEY WERE
CUT DURING THE GREAT RECESSION
AND NOT THE TWENTY ELEVEN BUT
GOING BACK FURTHER AND ALSO
PERMANENTLY RESTORING THE COST
OF LIVING INCREASE THANK YOU.
THANK. YOU MA'AM. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU TO
DR. AND THE COMMITTEE. MY NAME
IS JOHN SPEND I WILL SEND YOU
THE HEALTH CARE COVERAGE AND WE
ARE MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC IN COMPETITION IN THE
RIGHT ORGANIZATION CANNOT AT
AGENCIES. PROVIDING TO
CONSUMERS FOR HEALTH COVERAGE
AND WITH. NAVIGATING ACT CARE.
WE ONCE AGAIN THAT THE
COMMITTEE TO. HAVE A LOT OF
FIVE YOUR REQUEST FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE 202-120-2120
TWO BUDGET. I FIND THE MEDICARE
MEDICAID HEALTH NAVIGATOR
PROGRAM WHICH FUNDING WILL HELP
TO EXPAND STRENGTHENED AMID
EXISTING PILOT PROGRAMS TOWARD
CAN ABILITY. AS WELL DRAW DOWN
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL. FUNDS AT A
ONE TO ONE MATCH. YOU'RE
PROBABLY A L<c.cyan>G IN THAT.</c>
SEVENTY FIVE WE ARE STILL BUT
SHE TOOK HERSELF BARBECUE. NEXT
WE WILL GO ONLINE SEVENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO COMMENT THAT THE AUDIO
VOLUME FROM BENNETT THAT NIGHT
AT. WE ARE COMMENTING ON ISSUE
NUMBER FORTY NINE WHICH IS THE
RE PURPOSING OF FUNDING THAT
WAS APPROVED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT FOR THE CALVET OF
GRAHAM. FOR OTHER INTERACTIVE
EFFORTS. OUR ORGANIZATION IS
WORKING WITH HUNDREDS OF
PROVIDERS ACROSS THE STATE TO
GET THEM CONNECTED TO OUR
VALUABLE HEALTH INFORMATION
EXCHANGE. HOW FUN DUE TO THE
VERY LONG DELAY IN THIS PROGRAM
WE ARE RACING THE CLOCK TO GET
THIS WORK FINISHED. AND WE JUST
WANT TO BE SURE THAT THE STATE
CLARIFY. THAT THE FUNDS WILL
NOT BE BE PERFECT BEFORE THE
PROGRAM ENDS AT THE END OF
SEPTEMBER CURRENTLY THEY'RE
OPERATING UNDER. FEDERAL-
FUNDING- PLAN THAT WILL ALLOW
US TO WORK THE VERY LAST MINUTE
AT THE END OF SEPTEMBER COULD
BE SURE MORE PROVIDER CAN BE
CONNECTED. SO PLEASE- AND MAKE
SURE TO CLARIFY THAT THERE WILL
BE NO REPURPOSE THING OF
FUNDING UNTIL THE TOP PROGRAM
AND THAT THE END OF THE TWO. AT
WHICH POINT FUNDING CAN BE%
APPROPRIATE AND ALSO- GET
APPROVED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT FOR ADDITIONAL
PURPOSES. THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU MA'AM. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NINE THIRTY SEVENTY GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS MELISSA
BERRY AND I'M THE PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA NURSE MIDWIVES
ASSOCIATION AND I JUST WANTED
TO SHARE MY GRATITUDE FOR ITEM
NUMBER THIRTY FIVE AND THAT
WILL BENEFIT AND ITEM FORTY ONE
ON THE BENCH AND- EMAIL THAT.
DIRECT AIR IS ONE OF THE MOST
EVIDENCE BASED WAYS TO IMPROVE
OUTCOMES AND BIRTH ESPECIALLY
WITH WE DO THINGS WITH THEIR
INTERACTION RATES COSTS
INCLUDING PATIENT SATISFACTION
AND LOYALTY BUT THERE IS A VERY
LOW COST INTERVENTION THE COST
OF PRIVATE GIVE US THEIR NAMES.
UNTENABLE FOR MANY OTHER
MEDICAID RECIPIENTS INTO MAKING
THE BEST A COVERED BENEFIT WILL
DO A HUGE SERVICE AND THAT THE
IMPROVE IN THE DECEMBER OF. AND
BURN OUT- AND FURTHER. UP PARTY
HAVE WORDS FOR THE FIRST YEAR
FROM MEDICAID RECIPIENTS OF YOU
SO MUCH TO REDUCE THE AND HER
OF. COMPLICATIONS AT BIRTH THE
BOSTON GLOBE HI WHAT. I MEAN
YEAH THE QUESTION AND THE KIND
OF THING HAPPENED OF THE TOTAL
AND LYFT BECAUSE AGAIN JUST
WANTED MAKE FOR THE- APPROVING
AND HAVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT CALL. ONE FORTY FIVE GOING.
MY NAME IS MERRY BRIGHT AND I
AM THE OXYGEN CLINICAL
SPECIALTY FOR ALL TO CALIFORNIA
REGIONAL. STAGE SIR OVER TWO
SIX THOUSAND IN WHAT
DISABILITIES AND THE GREATER
TACKLE AREA. I UP ELIMINATE OF
THE DAY MAN CARE. AIMING SO
WOULD BE TO THE DD POPULAR AND
WOOD UNDOES OF HARDER IN
COLLABORATE IMPROVE PROJECT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. FIND TWO ARE
OPEN TO GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
CONNIE COMING PEDIATRIC DENTIST
AS WELL AS THE BILL ACTUALLY
ALL OPERATED ON OFFICERS
SACRAMENTO BEING GIVEN FULL
TIME DENTAL PRACTITIONER OVER
TWENTY FIVE YEARS I HAVE
DEVOTED ALMOST ALL MY DENTAL
PRACTICES TAKING CARE OF
MEDICARE. PATIENTS ESPECIALLY
THE- IN ADDITION AND DESPITE
CATHOLIC. TO PANIC HE PUT IT
THE MATH. I HAVE NEVER BEEN
OPPOSED I CAN DELIVER AND HAS
HAD THIS ISSUES LIMITED ACCESS
TO PEDIATRIC AND GENERAL I
DON'T CARE EVER I KNOW FOR FACT
THAT HE WOULD NOT SAVE MONEY IT.
INTO AN ACCOUNT IN YOU WILL OUR
PAY. IF YOU LIMIT THIS PRO. I
DON'T CLASS BECAUSE DELIVERED
THE OFFICE COURAGE ISN'T AS THE
THAT THE CHILD DON'T BENEATH.
AND COME MY TEAM I WAS CALDERON
THAT ROOM IDGAF PROGRAM IS THEY
MAY MY TEAM AND I AS WELL AS
THE POPULOUS WOULD YOU FOR YOUR-
BUT LET ME THINK SHE CALL.
THANK YOU SIR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. WE WILL TO LINE FOR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BRING YOUR OWN.
I'M A PRACTICING THAT
SACRAMENTO COUNTY ELIMINATE OF
DENTAL CARE PROGRAMS THAT
COUNTY. WELL CAN YOU REMEMBER
TO EAT DAY CARE COURT AND
QUALITY CARE THAT GENERAL
PROVIDE. FOR CERTAIN CANNOT DO
ALREADY ARE AT THE TOP TAKES.
ANY OF KNOCKED IN SACRAMENTO OR
L. A. COUNTY. THAT CAN TAKE SHE
FOR SERVICE- COMMITTEE MEMBERS
TO SPENT ON CARES AND DEAN YOU
TO BE. DEALT. PROGRAM TO
COTINUE HOW THEM WE NEED KIND
OF SERVICE. I AM THIS COMMITTEE
PLEASE OPPOSE BUILDING A
DOLLARS CARE PROGRAMS FOR
COUNTY. I WILL NOT IN THE
SCHOOL SOURCE SERVER SO THE-
THANK YOU HAVE A GREAT THANK
YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. MY
EIGHTY TWO EURO. IT UP CHAIR
AND MEMBERS HIRING THE- BUT THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTOR OF THE BOTH THE
LOOKING BACK ON FOR. A MENTION
BY AND WE FREDDIE WORKING ABOUT
YOU WHICH THAT HE A GREAT THE
PROPOSAL TO CARVE OUT
RESPONSIBILITY FIRST BATCH OF
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
BENEFIT FROM TIGHTER IN FACT I
DON'T WANT TO COUNTY THE COUNTY
THE COUNTY GOVERNMENT FOR
ROUGHLY TEN THOUSAND
BENEFICIARIES WITHOUT ADEQUATE
RESOURCES THAT SUPPORT TESE
INDIVIDUALS. ARE MORE ADEQUATE
TIGHTENING THE NOT A CHARACTER
MADE INCLUDE LESS THAN A
QUARTER OF THE FUNDING NEEDED
TO SUPPORT THE EVENT EVENTUAL
WE'RE DEFINITELY OPPOSED TO THE
TERMINATION- B. LPS ON STATE
HOSPITAL CONTRACTS WITH
COUNTIES WHICH WILL TRANSITION
SEVEN HUNDRED SEVENTY EIGHT OF
THEM OUT I'M VULNERABLE
MEDICALLY COMPLEX AND SOME
INDIVIDUALS WITH PUBLIC SAFETY
CONSIDERATIONS THE LOCAL LEVEL
WITHOUT APPROPRIATE PLACEMENT
AVAILABLE WE'RE ENGAGED IN
CONVERSATION ABOUT THAT.
MENTIONED BY MY COLLEAGUE AT
THE ATTACK ON WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO HELP WE COME
TO A RESOLUTION ON THAT ITEM-
CHAMPIONED BY DR RANDY A LOT WE
ARE HOPEFUL THAT THE ON
IMPLEMENTATION FUNDING NEEDED
TO ESTABLISH THAT YOUR SUPPORT
CERTIFICATION BACHELOR PROGRAM
UNDER AT THE EIGHT OH THREE
FROM LAST YEAR BUT THEN
MEDICARE WILL BE ALLOCATED AND
APPROVED. AND THEN ON THE
CHILDREN AND YOUTH PAYER HEALTH
INITIATIVE THE VAST MAJORITY OF
COUNTY ALREADY PROVIDES SCHOOL
BASED BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES AND HAVE DONE SO FOR
DECADES WE SUPPORT THE
ADMINISTRATIVE INITIATIVES THAT
BUILD UPON THE PARTNERSHIPS
WITH SCHOOLS TO ENSURE THAT
SERVICE THE CARD- DELIVERED TO
STUDENTS AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. WE WILL BETTER
ALIGN EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. EIGHT ONE YOU ARE OPEN.
YES THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
BURST BURST ON BEHALF OF THE
OCEAN AND AMERICAN COLLEGE
DISTRICT COLLEGE OBGYN
STRYCHNINE TRIPLE B. AND C. H.
E. BEHAVIOR SERVICES I'M ASKING
YOU TO CEMEX FOR SPORT INSIDE
WHERE SUPPORT OF THE STAGNATION
OF ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY NINE
RELATED TELEHEALTH TO REJECT
THE MINISTRATION GLOBAL AT DOT
THE MODIFIED PLACE ORDER
TROUBLING WHICH CONSISTENT WITH
AB THIRTY TWO. A LAST WEEK FOR
THE MEN COLLEGES DISTRICT NINE
AMERICA'S OBGYN SISTER NINE IN
SUPPORT OF THE STAFF OF NATION
BUT ISSUE NUMBER FORTY ONE TO
ADOPT ADMINISTRATION PROPOSAL
TO EXTEND POST PART OF MEDICARE
COVERAGE THANK YOU THE MEMBERS
AND. THEIR STAFF FOR ALL YOUR
HARD WORK ON THESE ISSUES.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
WE WILL ALIGN THIRTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU SO MUCH HI
MY NAME IS KARENA  WORK WITH
THE LET ME TO MAKE IT RIGHT THE
COALITION AND I'M HERE TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT PER ITEM THIRTY
Q. OUR ORGANIZATION WORKS TO
PEOPLE DIRECTLY IMPACTED BY THE
LACK OF HEALTH COVERAGE BETTER
NOT JUST LAST NIGHT FOR BETTER
VARIOUS ETHNICITIES. AND I WANT
TO I WANT TO THANK THE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S FOR INCLUDING
OUR COMMIT OUR COMMUNITY
MEMBERS THAT ARE FIFTY YEARS OF
AGE AND OLDER IN THIS PROPOSAL
BUT I REALLY DO WANT TO URGE
YOU TO CONSIDER EXPANDING IT
FOR ALL BECAUSE RACISM IS
INDEED A PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUE
AND IF IT DOESN'T AFFECT JUST
PEOPLE THAT ARE FIFTY. FIVE IT
AFFECTS EVERYBODY SO WE ARE
JUST ARE WE ARE STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF EXPANDING MEDICAL
FOR ALL AND WE WOULD URGE YOU
TO NOT WAIT FOR ANOTHER DEADLY
PANDEMICS TO REMIND US OF THE
IMPORTANCE OF PEOPLE'S LIVES
BECAUSE DUE TO THE LACK OF.
COVERAGE MANY UNDOCUMENTED
PEOPLE ARE DYING SLOWLY AND
RELYING ON HOME REMEDIES OR
EMERGENCY ROOMS TO TAKE CARE OF
THEIR HEALTH CONDITIONS IT'S
UNACCEPTABLE THAT THERE'S STILL
MILLIONS OF UNDOCUMENTED
CALIFORNIA THAT HAS GIVEN THEIR
BODIES FOR THE ECONOMY OF THE
STATE EVEN AMASSED A PANDEMIC.
TO PUT FOOD ON YOUR TABLE.
THAT'S EXPAND MY FOR A- THANK
THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER. EIGHTY
FOUR YOU ARE OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON TALKING
TEARING. SACRAMENTO PROGRAMS.%
MY PHONE IS A UNIQUE SCHOOL
BASED PROGRAMS THAT SERVE THE
MOST VULNERABLE CHILDREN AND
SACRAMENTO COUNTY BOARD THE
ONLY PROGRAM THAT PROVIDES.
PREVENTATIVE DENTAL SERVICES.
LAST TIME I DECLINED FROM AND
I'M SICK HELLO WE HAVE PROVIDED
PERMANENT SCREENING FOR FIFTY.
SIXTY THOUSAND FIVE TOTAL. AND
THIRTEEN CHECK PROVIDING
SERVICES TO TITLE ONE. SYSTEM.
I ALL FIFTEEN CENTER SCREEN
WILL PUNISH AND THAT WOULD BE
COULD NOT WHERE WE WILL WHAT'S
CALLED A- TEACHER AND OF COURSE
TO PAY THEIR SERVICES YEAH A
HERO TO TWENTY YEARS OLD. I
FOUND THAT AND THE POOR BY PM.
THE AND HELP BETTER CALIFORNIA
WHAT MAKES PROGRAM UNIQUE THAT.
CARE. THREE PM THREE THANK. TO
ON THE- COAST OF HOUSEHOLDS THE
TRAFFIC AND- IT'S- THAT I TRUMP
IS A AS FINE PART. PRESS FOR
AND. BUT. ONE MORE CALL FOR
LINE EIGHTY FIVE- I'M SORRY I
WAS ON MUTE NO WORRIES GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND- AND
MEMBERS THIS IS LORRAINE F. THE
TALLY HERE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
RURAL INDIAN HEALTH BOARD AND I
WANTED TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN. IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
REGARDING THE IMPORTANT HELP TO
STABILISE NAY FOR MERICAN
FAMILIES WITH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES FOR PARENTS IN THEIR
EFFORTS TOWARD EMPLOYMENT.
MITCHELL POST CODE RED- THANKYOU SOME FOR. TO THE FACTS AND
DATA WE HAVE PRESENTED
PREVIOUSLY AND ONCE AGAIN THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU MA'AM
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THIRTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD HI MY NAME IS
TYLER HAMMOND I AM A DISABILITY
RIGHTS. I AM A CHIP OF THE
SPENDING FOR THE SENSATION OF
LA ANIMALS SO AND THIS IS MY
ONE I'M A P. AND I WANTED TO
ABOUT. I REMEMBER FORTY SAID.
AND THAT'S EASY THE- AND I
THINK THAT WE HAVE A FRAUD
PREVENTION TO THE G. A. OFFICE
IN CALIFORNIA AND LOT OF MONEY
IS GOING INTO THE ELECTION.
OPPOSITE THAT THE- AND I THINK
IT'S COME AND THINK IT'S A WELL
IN- THE OTHER THING THAT I
WANTED TO MAKE IS. I ONE OF THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. THAT THE
MONEY HAS NOT BEEN REAL BAD TO
THEY FOR GOT INTO A CUTS THE
REST. AND AS A- ACTUALLY
STARTED CUTTING MY- INTO THE
EIGHT NINE. NINE TWO THOUSAND.
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN GIVES A I
DON'T KNOW NOT DOLLARS. I'M I'M
AND IF IT WAS THAT WHICH BE
BACK IT WOULD BE A MISTAKE LIKE
SIXTY TWO SIXTY DOLLARS RANGE-
I'D LIKE TO THINK. ASSEMBLY AND
FRAZIER. SUBPOENA FRIEND. WHAT
OCCURRED AT THE BEGINNING- I
LOVE THE WAY THAT YOU'RE
THINKING ABOUT I
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED
COMMUNITY WE NEED. TO SUGGEST
YOU KNOW SOMEHOW. A LITTLE BIT
OF HELP FOR A KIDS TO LIVE WITH
LIFE. AND THANK YOU. FOR YOUR
CARE. THANK YOU NEXT WERE
PLEASE IN. THANK YOU WE WILL
EIGHTY SO. I WAS JUST GATLIN
BACK OUT STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES WONDER ON. PART BE I
NUMBER FOUR ON THE ICE THAT
STATE COUNTY RATIO. HOW WE CAN
TO STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BUT
AND THAT WE'VE MADE WITH THE
COMMITTEE DIMINISH. I TO
RESERVE THE WONDER WE HAD WITH
THE ADMIN MAYBE VICE RELATED TO
HOW MANY TIMES COUNTY- CAN YOU
THE TEMPER OVER THREE YEARS TO
ALL THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU NEXT PLEASE. EIGHTY EIGHT
PLEASE CALL. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR BURTON GIVEN THE COUNTY
EFFECTS THE FIFTH OF HOW. WHEN
I FIRST THANK YOU FOR THE
DISCUSSION FOR A MENTION OF
PUBLIC HEALTH IN EFFECT DISEASE-
THE ONE THING THAT I WOULD ASK
DELIVER ARE TOWARD THAT THE.
THAT INVESTMENT NOW SO THAT
PUBLIC HEALTH CAN CAN REALLY
PICK UP IN BOTH- THEIR STAFFING
CAPACITY THAT THEY CAN TACKLE
MANY AT HEALTH ISSUES THAT
AWAIT THEM THANK YOU THANK YOU
MA'AM NEXT PLEASE. EIGHTY NINE
YOU PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MISTER
J. AND MEMBERS OF IS CARL
DIDN'T ON BEHALF OF THE LAW
SUPPORTING WITH IT AND AS A
YEAH MAN WITH AIDID. AND I
WHICH IS LIKETO THANK THE CON
OF MR FRAZIER MISSED MATHIS
TODAY BUT YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND THE BEST ROUTE FROM PRIOR
HEARING. ON INDEED TO HOLD
COULD BASED. TO PEOPLE WITH
INTELLECTUAL OF ALL DISABILITY-
ARE NOT THE CAUSE OF THE TWENTY
YEAR CHRONIC UNDER OF SYSTEM
THAT IS A. BUT YOU THE LETTER
LATER CHARACTER HAVE THIS GUY.
AND IN A YEAR WE HAVE A PRESS
BUDGET SIR. AND IN OF DRUG FUND
IT'S TIME TO FIVE KERR THIS
ISSUE AND BRING RATES UP TO A
LEVEL THE COMMUNITY CAN PROVIDE
QUALITY SERVICE. AND THE STAFF
YOU HAVE TO LIVE WITH A PA
LEVEL THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME THANK YOU SIR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. WE WILL GO
ONLINE FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS JONES I AM
A PARENT CONSUMER AND NOW
CULTURE L. A. HEALTH CARE PLAN
ACT INCLUSION WORK FIRST GROUP.
FOURTEEN EQUITIES AS AN
IMPORTANT NEED IN A FRONTLINE
MATTER I THANK YOU FOR
SUPPORTING THE MEASURES.
686-970-7170 TWO. SEVENTY THREE
AND NINETY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CARE AND COUNTY. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. I NINETY YOU ARE
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD NINETY.
HELLO MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE IT'S AND
JORDAN AND THE WITH THE OUR
COMMUNITY WILL PULL THE
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATION- FIRST
AND FOREMOST I JUST WANT TO
QUICKLY EXPRESSED DEEP
APPRECIATION TO THE COMMITTEE
AND ITS STAFF OVER THE LAST
COUPLE YEARS YOU HAVE. GUIDED
THE STATE THROUGH VERY TRYING
TIMES AND YOU'RE PROTECTED
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES-
THROUGHOUT THE SO THANK YOU TO
THE CORRECT COMMITMENT YOU HAVE
SHOWN- AND THEN SECONDS WANT TO
COMMENT ON THE ITEMS IN THE DDS
BUDGET- QUICKLY ONE ONE AT A
SURE APPRECIATION FOR
PARTICULAR THE ITEM FOR DSP
TRAINING AND CERTIFICATION
ALONG WITH. WAGE INCREASE AT
ALL GO IN EFFECT BUT THAT
DOESN'T GOING AFFECTED FOR
ANOTHER TWO OR THREE YEARS. SO
ALL FOUR LINES. MY WITH COMMON
MADE AT THE HEARING FOR BY. MR
FRAZIER MISTER MATHIS. AS WELL
COMMENTS MADE BY YOU MISTER
PREVIOUS MET THROUGH- THE NEW
FOR COULD INVEST AND WE THAT
CAN HAVE. DURING THIS BUDGET
CYCLE NOT IN A IN AUGUST IF.
NECESSARY BUT WE HOPE THAT
THERE IS STILL TIME THE NEXT
COMING DAYS WE'RE DEDICATED TO
WORKING WITH YOU IN FINDING
THAT SOLUTION TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE CAN PROVIDE QUALITY SERVICES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
SIR. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE
SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS
MY NAME IS FRED NO WHERE
REPRESENTING THE PHARMACEUTICAL
RESEARCH AND MANUFACTURERS OF
AMERICA AND A FORMER ONCE THE
SUB COMMITTEE TO KNOW THAT WE
GRAYSON CONCERNS WITHOUT
LANGUAGE PROPOSED BY THE OFFICE
OF STATEWIDE HEALTH PLANNING
AND DEVELOPMENT. TO THEIR S. B.
SEVENTEEN DRUG PRICE REPORTING
FUNCTION THIS IS UNDER ISSUE
NUMBER SIX. WE PLAY OUR
CONCERNS ARE THREEFOLD THE
DEFINITIONS PROVOKED A POSED
FOR DIFFERENT CATEGORIES OF
DRUGS. IN OUR OPINION OR NOT
CONSISTENT WITH FEDERAL LAW.
AND WE ALSO ARE HOPING TO
CLARIFY THE LANGUAGE FOR THE
LOOK BACK PERIOD FOR REPORTING.
AND LAST WEEK THE PROPOSED
LANGUAGE FROM THE OFFICE GIPSON
FURTHER A PROPERTY TO DETERMINE
WHETHER A REPORTING MANUFACTURE
IS DOING SO IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THE LAW. WE HAVE NO OBJECTION
WITH THEM DOING SO OF COURSE
BUT THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS ARE
NOT SUFFICIENTLY CLEAR WE ARE
SIMPLY ASKING. TO WORK ON THE
LANGUAGE SO THERE IS CLARITY ON
WHAT IT DEEMS TO BE COMPLIANT
REPORTING WE'VE MET WITH THE
OFFICE AND ARE HOPEFUL THROUGH
SUBMISSION OF US SOME SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS WE CAN RESOLVE THESE
ISSUES. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN PRESENT ALSO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THE SUPPORT OF
COMMENTS ABOUT ALS CARE. ACT IN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU I'M
SEVENTY SEVEN YOU ARE OPEN. OUR
SKEWS ME I TAKE THAT BACK POINT
SEVENTY FOUR YOU ARE OPEN.
THANK YOU AND THE CHICKEN
CHAIRING COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
STAFF FOR YOUR WORK. THE TICKET
NEED BOARD ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ATTACK
WOMEN AND GIRLS WE'RE
INDEPENDENT ADVISORY AGENCY ON
ISSUES AFFECTING EQUITY FOR
WOMEN AND GIRLS. ARE WE WANT TO
ADD YOUR SUPPORT AND I THINK
THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
SUBCOMMITTEE ON I AM THIRTY
SEVEN TO COVER DEAL WITH
EVERYTHING. AND A MEDIC CAL
PROGRAM AND I AM FORTY ONE TO
EXPAND MEDICARE ELIGIBILITY
FROM SIXTY DAYS TO TWELVE
MONTHS FOR BOTH PART OF
INDIVIDUALS. AND LASTLY WE
SUPPORT THIS COMMITTEE'S
RECOMMENDATION ON ITEM TWENTY
NINE SHORELINE THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE- AROUND TELEHEALTH
FLEXIBILITY AB THIRTY TWO.
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND HAVE A GOOD DAY. THANK YOU
MA'AM THANKS CALLER. BY NINETY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS UP PERCENT OF ALL OF
WITH THE WORKING- COALITION FOR
HEALTHY CALIFORNIA I'M BUDGET
GOING TO REMARK ON ITEM NUMBER
THIRTY TWO- WITH THE POSITIVE
NEWS THAT YOU KNOW THE BUDGET
IS IN SURPLUS. WE SUPPORT
OBVIOUSLY GOING TO GET MANY
PEOPLE INCLUDING THE
UNDOCUMENTED ON SCHIBETTA CAL-
SO WE THINK THE ASSEMBLY
FURTHER LEADERSHIP ON WHAT'S-
BUT WE ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT THE
URGENCY FOR. AROUND WITH SO IF
YOU'RE- AND WE NEED TO DO AS
MUCH AS POSSIBLE FOR- ARE
ELDERLY AND ARE DOCUMENTED THAT
HAVE. REALLY PUSHED US THROUGH
THIS- THIS ENTIRE PANDEMIC. SO-
THANK YOU. KISSER NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. OVERLIE NINETY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI FIFTY
PHOEBE ABRAMOWITZ CALLING FROM
LOS ANGELES I'M AN ORGANIZER
WITH THE HELP FOR ALL COALITION
OF OVER A HUNDRED ORGANIZATIONS
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF INCLUDING
AS MANY UNDOCUMENTED PEOPLE AS
POSSIBLE THE MEDIC HOW THIS
YEAR- SOME CALIFORNIA HAS A
BUDGET BUDGET BUDGET AND A
SURPLUS THERE'S NOTHING YOU'VE
GOT THE BEST IN THE
UNDOCUMENTED COMMUNITY GO FOR
THE BRANDS OF COVERT NINETEEN
AND CONTRIBUTE SO MUCH TO ALL
OF OUR COMMUNITY. THANK YOUR
FAMILY MEMBERS FOR INCLUDING
OUR COMMUNITY MEMBERS. IN OLDER
IN THE PROPOSAL. THANK YOU
MA'AM NEXT CALL PLEASE. WHY ONE
HUNDRED YOU ARE OPEN. THERE TO
CATCH ON BEHALF OF THE RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES THE
CALIFORNIA COMMENTING ON
SEVERAL PROPOSAL. IT STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR ISSUE
NUMBER TWENTY NINE HELLO
SERVICES FOR AUDIO ONLY THIRTY
THIRTY. BE DIFFICULT TO.
SUPPORT FOR ITEM THIRTY TO
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CONTINUUM
INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAM YEAH THE
POOR AND PART B. I AM FOR I
EACH AFFECT STATE AND COUNTY
SHARING RATIO PROPOSAL. TO LACK
OF CONTINUATION OF THE FACT
STATE AND 35% SHARING RATIO AND
THE CONTINUATION OF THE 10%
OVER A YEAR OP- OPTIONS. OUR
SECURITY REMAINS A PUBLIC ISSUE
SEVENTY FOUR TO DISCONTINUE
BOTTOM PATRICK SHARKEY POSSIBLE
CONTRACTS WITH COUNTY CURRENT
CAMERI THE SOCIAL DEMOCRATS
OPPOSE ON. THE POCKET CHANGE
NEED ADEQUATE TRAINING FOR
COUNTY THE STATE THE PLAN FOR
THE POPULATION NEEDS ENSURE
THINK OF AL GORE CORPORATE
COMMUNITY THOUGHT TURNER.
ACCEPT PRIVATE PRIOR TO
DISCHARGE ECHO PREVIOUS
COMMENTS BY FEEDBACK IN COUNTY
PARTNERS REGARDING CONTINUE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION THE FINAL
RESOLUTION ON THAT ISSUE.
BLACKS THE REPORT ISSUE SIXTY
FOUR FOR A PANDEMIC RESPONSE
REVIEW AN AD BUDGET
DELIBERATIONS CONTINUE OUR
THIRTY- GIVE CONSIDERATION AT
THAT CALIFORNIA CAN'T WAIT BUT
YOUR QUESTION BACK YOUNGER
MILLION ONGOING. SUPPORT LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENT. WORKFORCE
INFRASTRUCTURE THANK YOU. THANK
YU MA'AM NEXT CALLER. NEXT WE
WILL GO TO LINE EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU TURN COMMITTEE
MAN MANY THE SITES WITH THE
ASIA RESOURCE ACTION. I'M
SPEAKING OF I THIRTY TOOK SPEND
THAT COVERAGE TEN DOT ADULTS
AGE THE AND OLDER AND WE ECHO
THE COMMENTS FROM OUR PARTNERS
THAT WITH POSITIVE NEWS ABOUT
CALIFORNIA'S BUDGET SURPLUS NOW
IS THE TIME TO INCLUDE AS MANY
UNDOCUMENTED PEOPLE COMFORTABLE
IN THAT ACCOUNT. AND THEN IT'S
IMPERATIVE THAT WE NO LONGER
EXCLUDE MILLIONS OF LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS SIMPLY BECAUSE OF
THEIR IMMIGRATION STATUS. URGES
THE COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT THIS
PROPOSAL AND EXPAND THAT
ACCOUNT ALL BECAUSE
CALIFORNIA'S YOUNGER WHEN
EVERYONE IS COVERED AND HEALTHY
THANK YOU. THANK. YOU MA'AM.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. PINE ONE-
TO YOUR OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
SHERRY MEMBERS JAMIE OFTEN WITH
TAKING MY COMMUNITY AS A MEMBER
OF THE TRUTH INTERESTED IN
CHILD SUPPORT COALITION A
COALITION OF DOESN'T NEED
GROUPS ACROSS CALIFORNIA I URGE
THE COMMITTEE TO ONE ENSURE A
PERCENT OF ALL TRANSPORT
PAYMENTS GO DIRECTLY THE CHILD
TOOK TWO CHILDREN. TO ELIMINATE
GOVERNOR'S ISLAND CHOCOLATE
FORGET AND THE 10% THAT ON
INTEREST FIVE THIRD AND DRIVERS
LICENSE SUSPENSION FOR
INABILITY TO PAY CHILD SUPPORT
AND FOURTH. ENSURE ANY
GARNISHMENT OF THE GOLDEN STATE
KILLER CHECK FOR TOP REPORT
THAT GO DIRECTLY TO CHILDREN
I'M NOT A FACT THE GOVERNMENT
OWED. CHILD SUPPORT THAT. HE TO
ME FOR. IT'S A SURE FIRE WAY TO
INVEST IN LOW INCOME. THANK
FAMILY CAN. AND HELP CAL THE
COVER THANK YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. FIND
ONE HUNDRED ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AFTERNOON THIS IS DANIEL-
CONFER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FOUNDATION FOR INDEPENDENT
LIVING CENTERS- WE ARE A
STATEWIDE MEMBERSHIP
ASSOCIATION MADE UP OF TWENTY
FOUR CALIFORNIANS TWENTY EIGHT
INDEPENDENT CENTERS. AND WE
REPRESENT DETECTIVES THE COUNTY
IN THE STATE- I'LL SEE WAS ONE
OF THIRTY FOUR INDICATIONS THAT
WERE INVOLVED IN THE MASTER
PLAN FOR AGING ADVISORY
COMMITTEE AND ONE OF THE-
FOLLOWING GROWING IT WAS IN THE
INVESTMENT AND THE AGING AND
DISABILITY RESOURCE CONNECTION
FOR EIGHTY D. R. C.'S. TERRIBLE
STUFF ON THE WRONG DOOR MODEL
THEIR THIRD BOTH INITIAL.
DISABILITIES AND OLDER ADULTS-
YOU SUPPORT THE NEEDS- ADDRESS
AND I DIDN'T SEVENTY THIRD
THREE AND THE- OF THE BUDGET-
INCLUDING- THE NEED TO INCREASE.
THE ON WITH THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSED AND WE ALSO WANT TO
ECHO OUR- OPPOSITION TO ITEM
FORTY SEVEN IN DEPARTMENT
SOCIAL SERVICES. AND WE JOINED
ALONG WITH THIRTY OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS WERE OPPOSED TO
THE PROPOSED TO THE L. THREE P.
ALL THE- PROMOTION OF THE USE
OF GEO TRACKING THEM YES OR
EASY THE- THE CROCKER
EDUCATION. COOPER I JUST SAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
TIGHTENING. THANK YOU SIR. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. GOING ALONG WILL
GO TO LINE. NINETY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU FOR SHARING
THAT BIRTH MADELINE COOPER
ABOUT HALF OF THE COUNTY OF SAN
DIEGO I HAVE COMMENTS ON
SEVERAL PROPOSALS ON ISSUES
SEVENTY FOUR WE'RE GOING TO
COUNTY COALITION IN OPPOSING
THE MAY REVISION PROPOSAL TO
DISCONTINUE THE STATE HOSPITAL
CONTRACT. WITH COUNTIES LPS
CONSERVATIVE. ONE ITEM NINE.
YOUR QUESTION IN CREATE IN
FUNDING. THEY FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE ACT THAT
PSA FROM A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
TWO POINT FOURMILLION TO TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION OVER
THREE YEARS AND LASTLY ITEM FOR
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE
PROPOSAL INCLUDED IN THE MAY
REVISION THAT IT STANDS THE
CONTINUATION OF THAT 65% STATE
AND 35% COUNTY SHARING RATIO
AND THE CONTINUATION OF THE 10%
OVER THREE YEARS OPTIONS. WE
REQUEST THAT THE CAP OF USING
THE 10% COUNTY OPTION TO ONLY
TWO TIMES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MA'AM NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE
HUNDRED AND SIX YOU ARE OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
TONY LAMBERT AND I AM A SCHOOL
NURSE SACRAMENTO CITY UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT- AND I AM
ASKING THAT YOU OPPOSE
ELIMINATION AT THE DENTAL
MANAGED CARE PROGRAM. THEY'RE A
LIFELINE FOR MY SCHOOL
COMMUNITY OFF OF BROADWAY. AND
ALSO I THINK HELP FOR OTHER
SCHOOL NURSES IN THE DISTRICT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. ONE HUNDRED
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON- MISTER DORIAN THAT
GREW ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSOCIATION
COMMENTING ON ITEM FORTY TWO.
STRONGLY SUPPORTS THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
ELIMINATE THE TWENTY FIVE YEAR
OLD FAILING PILOT IN LOS
ANGELES AND SACRAMENTO AND
TRANSITION BACK TO FEE FOR
SERVICE DENTAL SYSTEM THE FACTS
ARE NOT IDENTICAL PROGRAM HAS
DRASTICALLY IMPROVED OVER THE
PAST FIVE YEARS AND IT'S NOT
WHAT IT WAS. AT TEN FIFTEEN
TWENTY FIVE YEARS AGO. IN THE
PAST SEVERAL YEARS UTILIZATION
HAVE GONE UP SIGNIFICANTLY OF
DENTAL SERVICES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AND YET EIGHT HUNDRED
THOUSAND BENEFICIARIES ARE
STUCK IN THE SYSTEM. BUT IT'S
STILL FAILING THOSE MEMBERS.
BNP PLANT UNDERPERFORM THE REST
OF THE STATE IN EVERY SINGLE
METRIC USED TO MEASURE THE
HEALTH THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
DESPITE THEIR MANY INVESTMENTS
IN CARE COORDINATION PATIENT
NAVIGATION AND OTHERS ARE.
STILL NO EVIDENCE TO BACK UP
CLAIMS THAT THE QUALITY IS
BETTER COMPARED TO PAY FOR
SERVICE. MEDICARE NEEDS TO MAKE
THESE CHANGES TO EQUALIZE
IMPROVEMENTS MADE ACROSS THE
STATE AND DELIVERING MORE
CONSISTENT PROGRAM DO YOU HAVE
YEAH HAVE ENGAGE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT IN DEVELOPING THEIR
TRANSITION PLANS. AND SUPPORT
ELIMINATION OF THE EXPERIMENT
RESTORING THE FOR SERVICE IN
THESE TWO COUNTIES IS IN THE
BEST INTEREST OF THE ORAL
HEALTH OF BENEFICIARY THANK%
YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. WHAT TEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS TRENT SMITH ON BEHALF
OF PUBLIC CONSERVATIVES AND
PUBLIC GUARDIANS SHARING OUR
OPPOSITION TO THE STATE
HOSPITAL PROPOSAL CLEAR RETURN
LPS CONSERVING THESE BACK TO
THE COUNTY LEVEL WE SHARE THE
SAME CONCERNS OF THEIR COUNTY
PARTNERS WITH REGARDS TO THE
LACK OF PLACEMENT FOR THESE
FACILITIES. IN ADDITION WE ARE
CONCERNED THAT THERE IS NO
FUNDING FOR PUBLIC
CONSERVATIVES THE PUBLIC
GUARDIAN'S WHICH- REMAIN UNDER
FUNDED AND THE STATE HAS NEVER
CONTRIBUTED TO ANY OF THEIR
SERVICES AND WE'RE SPEAKING
WITH FINANCIAL SUPPORT FROM THE
STATE. FOR THEIR SERVICES THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU SIR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE SEVENTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS AND STAFF MY NAME
IS SEAN YOUNG WITH THE SAN
FRANCISCO FINANCIAL JUSTICE
PROJECT THE OFFICE OF THE
DEPUTY TREASURER I'M AS A
MEMBER OF THE TRUTH AND JUSTICE
CHILD SUPPORT COLLECTION- A
COALITION OF DOESN'T THE
COMMUNITY GROUPS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. I'M NOT LIKE TO
COMMENT ON PART B. IF YOU
SEVENTY NINE ALMOND THANK DR
ARAMBULA FOR ON YOUR END UP ON-YOUR STANDING OF THE BURDEN
THAT GOVERNMENT- CHILD SUPPORT
DEBT PLACES ON OUR STATE. OUR
LOW INCOME FAMILIES THAT YOU'VE
DEMONSTRATED IN PREVIOUS
HEARINGS AND COMMENTS I'M I'M
CALLING TODAY SECOND THE
COMMENTS MADE BY US SEVEN POINT
UNITY AND STRONGLY URGE. THE
COMMITTEE TO INVEST IN LOW
INCOME FAMILIES BY FIRST
ENSURING THAT A 100% OF ALL
CHILD SUPPORT PAYMENTS GO
DIRECTLY TO CHILDREN AND
SECOND. ELIMINATING GOVERNMENT-
CHILD SUPPORT DEBT IN 10%
INTEREST RATE PAYMENTS ON THIS
DEBT EACH YEAR THE STATE TAKE
FOUR HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS IN
CHILD SUPPORT PAYMENTS FROM LOW
INCOME CHILDREN THE PEOPLE WHO
MAKE THESE TYPES OF CHILD
SUPPORT PAYMENTS ARE PRIMARILY
BLACK AND BROWN LOW INCOME
BOTHERS YOU ALREADY PAY. FOR
THE COST OF OUR SOCIAL SAFETY
NET OF TAXES THE STATE SHOULD
NOT FORCE PARENTS THE PAPER
TWICE ESPECIALLY NOT BY
STRIPPING AWAY MONEY THAT
SHOULD BE GOING DIRECTLY TO
CHILDREN. GOVERNMENT SHOULD NOT
BE MAKING IT HARDER FOR LOW
INCOME PARENTS OF COLOR TO
SUPPORT THEIR FAMILIES AND
RELIEVING THE BURDEN OF
GOVERNMENT- CHILD SUPPORT AND
ENSURING THAT MONEY GO DIRECTLY
TO CHILDREN IS ONE OF THE MOST
EFFECTIVE WAY TO STRENGTHENING
COMMUNITIES HIT HARDEST BY THE
PANDEMIC. BOB THANK YOU AGAIN
DR ARAMBULA MEMBERS AND STAFF
FOR ALL YOUR MARKET FOR LOW
INCOME CHILDREN FAMILIES AND I
HOPE THAT YOU USED OUR HISTORIC
BUDGET SURPLUS TO DIRECTLY
INVEST IN FAMILIES IN OUR CHILD
SUPPORT SYSTEM THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE
HUNDRED NAY YOU ARE. GOOD AT MY
IS DUNCAN I AM A FAN DOCTOR
FROM SANTA ROSA CAL CALLING
ITEM THIRTY TWO IN STRONG
SUPPORT THE CONTINUED EXPANSION
OF FUNDING. FOR HEALTHCARE
PROBLEM DOCUMENTED FIVE
PARTICULAR WORK AT OUR LARGEST
STOP FAMILY QUALIFIED HEALTH
CENTER SERVING A LARGE
POPULATION OF UNDOCUMENTED
PICTURES SO I BEAR TESTIMONY
EVERY SINGLE DAY THE DICHOTOMY
OF SIMILARLY ONE PATIENT.
COMPLAINED THAT ALREADY HAS
MEDIC CAL. FIRST OF MY NECK
ISSUE COULD THIS EXACT SAME PER
PATIENT AND I BARELY THAT DAY
TO THE WORK OUT THAT. TO MY
VERY PATIENTS ONE AND ONE
O'CLOCK I'LL CALIFORNIA YOU'VE
GOT ARE SO TO MAKE US A LEADER
IN THE COUNTRY WE ARE ARE AND
BY CO. OF BECOMING MORE PEOPLE
WE WILL CHECK- ONE POINT A PATH
TO REALLY DEMONSTRATING THAT
HEALTHCARE IS A RIGHT FOR ALL
AND IT NOT ONLY GIVES THE RIGHT
BUT IT MAKES A LOT OF DOLLARS
AND I KNOW WHEN WE STUDY THAT
FROM YOU CAN. WE WILL HAVE
SHOWN THAT THE COULD I GET
DOLLARS STATEMENT BY KEEPING.
CRITICAL PEOPLE IN OUR SOCIETY
WHO ARE HELPING TO SUPPORT- BY
COVERING THEM. AND KEEPING THEM
HEALTHY. AT THE END OF MUCH WHY
INVEST OF PUBLIC DOLLARS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU SIR
MEXICO PLEASE. THE MOVING ALONG
WITH A LINE. HUNDRED THIRTEEN
YOU ARE OPEN. SH HELLO MY NAME
IS PARA MILITARY I AM THE
SCHOOL NURSE AT ONE UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT ABOUT
PROJECTION CENTER I'M CALLING
TO OPPOSE THE ELIMINATION OF
THE DENTAL MANAGED CARE PROGRAM
IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY I ASK YOU
TO PLEASE OPPOSE THE
ELIMINATION OF THE DENTAL
MANAGED CARE PROGRAM FROM MY
COMMUNITY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MA'AM NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE
HUNDRED ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ARE YOU- MY NAME IS DAN
HOEGAARDEN THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF LOS TRUMPET-
SERVING ADULTS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES AND
FEDERAL CONTRA COSTA COUNTY I
WANT TO THANK YOU- CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBER FOR ALL OF
YOUR SUPPORT TO THE
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES- COMMUNITY OVER
THE YEARS- AND I REALLY SORT OF
WANT TO ADDRESS A COUPLE OF
THINGS. YOU WE HAVE BEEN HERE
AN OPPORTUNITY HERE TO DEVELOP
OUR TO DIRECT SERVICE
PROFESSIONALS AND I SUPPORT
THAT HOWEVER. WE'RE GONNA NEED
DIRECTOR PROFESSIONALS TO TRAIN
AND IT TO THE BALLOT. GOING
FORWARD AND CURRENTLY THE WAY
WERE FUNDED WE'RE NOT GOING TO
HAVE VERY MANY OF THEM IT'S
BEEN A VERY ROUGH YEAR PRESS
AND I KNOW THAT I'VE LOST A LOT
OF- MY STAFF. DO YOU TO CO BID
EACH COVERED RELATED ISSUES AND
THEY'RE NOT WILLING TO COME
BACK AT THAT TIME AND- I'M
HAVING A HARD TIME GETTING MORE
STAFF TO COME BACK IN SO I'M
ASKING AT THE TIME THAT WE-
BONDED DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES.
TO THE POLITICS OF THE RATE
STEADY AND FILL THAT GAP- IT'S
TIME AND I KNOW THAT YOU'RE ON
BOARD WITH THAT PLEASE MAKE
THAT HAPPEN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SIR. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS KELLY MAC MILLAN WITH THE
MARCH OF DIMES AND I JUST
WANTED TO CALL AND THANK THE
CHAIR AND MEMBERS FOR
SUPPORTING ISSUE THIRTY SEVEN
THE DOUBLE THE BENEFIT AND ALSO
ISSUE FEB FORTY ONE THE
MEDICARE ELIGIBILITY EXTENSION
FOR POSTPARTUM INDIVIDUALS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
MA'AM. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE
HUNDRED SIXTEEN YOU ARE OPEN.
DR JANE COMPEL PARTICIPATION AT
THE BANK JUST BRIEFLY THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR CONTINUED
LEADERSHIP TO END HUNGER IN THE
BUDGET DEEPLY GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
COMMENTS TODAY KNOW WHAT IMPACT
THAT MAKES FOR THE FOOD BANKS
THAT SERVE YOUR DISTRICT AND
ACROSS THE STATE WE REALLY ARE
STILL IN IN DEEP NEED-
APPRECIATE AS WELL THE ASSEMBLY
LONG SUPPORT FOR AT THE SCIENCE
OPEN FOR BOTH RESTORATION OF
THE GRANTS. ON THE OTHER
CONVERSATIONS THEY'RE HAVING
WITH YOU AND YOUR STAFF THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU SIR.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE
HUNDRED. PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR IN
MEMBERS JAMIE MORGAN ON BEHALF
OF THE AMERICAN HEART
ASSOCIATION CALLING IT PART OF
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY NINE RELATED
TO MEDICALLY TAILORED MEALS.
THE AMERICAN HEART ASSOCIATION
RECOGNIZES THE IMPORTANT
ACCIDENT MEDICINE PROGRAMS AND
SPORTS ACTIVITIES THAT AIM TO
INCREASE ACCESS TO HEALTHY FOOD
ACROSS THE CARE CONTINUUM.
GIVEN THE DIRECT CORRELATION
BETWEEN DIETARY HABITS HEALTH
AS WELL AS THE ABUNDANCE OF
EVIDENCE SUPPORTING HOW EVEN
SMALL DIETARY CHANGES CAN HELP
PREVENT AND TREAT DISEASE
MAKING AND MAINTAINING ACCESS
TO MEDICALLY TAILORED MEALS ARE
THE BENEFITS AND SERVICES
AVAILABLE TO MEDI CAL
BENEFICIARIES WE BELIEVE HEALTH
OUTCOMES COULD. BE IMPROVED IN
COP. THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU MA'AM. NEXT CALL PLEASE.
WINE ONE HUNDRED TWENTY TWO YOU
ARE OPEN. HELLO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS DOCTOR DOCTOR ARAMBULA-
THIS IS JENNIFER MALLEY WITH
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
AND JUST WANTED TO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THE
MATTER OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES PARTICULARLY DURING
THE PANDEMIC. AND ALSO JUST
TAKING THE LEAD ON ENSURING
THAT HEALTHCARE CAN BE
AFFORDABLE AND ACCESSIBLE
KEEPING MOST VULNERABLE. I
WANTED TO EXPRESS HER STRONG
SUPPORT FOR EXPANDING MEDICAID
UNDOCUMENTED OLDER ADULTS BUT-
REALLY WOULD LOVE TO BE- AB
GREATER BROAD NAME OF MEDIC
HOUSE TO ALL. AND I ALSO WANTED
TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR.
MAINTAINING THE SIXTY FIVE
THIRTY FIVE SPLIT RATIO- AND
PART B- PARTICULARLY TO THE I.
HFS WORKER SO THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP AND- LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU ON
THE OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY. THANK YOU MA'AM
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS DR MARY JANE
WILSON I'M A PEDIATRICIAN
WORKING FOR CALIFORNIA CHILDREN.
YEAH I AM CALLING TO YOUR
LIMITATION SACRAMENTO COUNTY
DENTAL MANAGED CARE PROGRAM
WHICH BENEFITED OUR COMMUNITY
INCLUDING CHILDREN WITH SPECIAL
HEALTH CARE NEEDS I THANK YOU
TO OPPOSE THE ELIMINATION OF
DENTAL MANAGED CARE FOR
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES WHO WOULD
OTHERWISE STRUGGLE WITH ACCESS.
TO DENTAL SERVICES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK. YOU MA'AM NEXT
CALL PLEASE. TWENTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON LED
THE WAY WITH THE WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY UNDER PART
B. TO HELP AGENT THAT WE WANT
TO THANK THE ASSEMBLY FOR GOING
BEYOND THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL TO EXPAND MEDICAID
HEALTH UNDOCUMENTED ADULT TO
INCLUDE ADULTS AGE FIFTY PLUS
AS AN IMPORTANT STEP TO GET TO
ALL WE ALSO PREACH APPRECIATE
ITEM TO EXPAND PUT PART OF
ELIGIBILITY TO ALASKA NEW
MEXICO CLOSE MONITORING.
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKER
COVERAGE AND ACCELERATED
ENROLLMENT IMPLEMENTATION AS
WELL AS DEALING OUT THE COVER
CALIFORNIA ONE DOLLAR PREMIUM
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE SUBCOMMITTEE ON ITEMS THAT
WERE NOT INCLUDED IN THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL
INCLUDING ELIMINATION OF THE
ACID TEST ONE TIME INVESTMENT
TO BUILD THAT HOUSING SUPPORT.
BILL CASTING AGENCY LANGUAGE
ACTIVE PROPOSAL AND ADDING
IMPORTANT CONSUMER PROTECTION
IN THE PROPOSAL TO ELIMINATE
DENTAL MANAGED CARE THANK YOU
THANK. YOU MATTER. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. BY ONE TWENTY SIX PLAY
GO AHEAD. HI THE IS LABATT
MENTAL BY WITH IN COALITION FOR
IMMIGRANT JOB FAIR- OUT HERE IN
DECEMBER DINO RIVERSIDE COUNTY
AND WITH THE POSITIVE NEWS OF
THIS HEALTHY BUDGET ENTERPRISE
ARE WE WANT TO CONTINUE TO PUSH
FOR THE HEALTH AND WELLNESS. OF
OUR UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANT
PEOPLE- AND WE WANT MEDIC
CALISTHENICS POSSIBLE FOR THEM
YOU KNOW AS MANY OTHERS HAVE
SINCE SHARED WE DON'T WE THINK
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS. INCLUDING
OUR COMMUNITY MEMBERS OF FIFTY
AND OLDER IN THIS PROPOSAL OF
THE COLD TO SEE THAT WILL GO
THROUGH YOU YOU UNDERSTAND THAT
THESE ARE THE ESSENTIAL
WORKERS- WHO WILL HAVE BEEN
EXPOSED TO THEIR WORK AND ARE
STILL IN NEED OF COVERAGE OR
HEARING OF A COLD- THE REACTION
OF THE FACT THAT OF KOBE AND I
WAS JUST ON A CALL. WHERE I
LEARNED- FROM SOME HORRENDOUS
STORIES OF WHAT PEOPLE ARE
DEALING WITH EVEN- COLD AND SO
THE PANDEMIC IS NOT OVER LET'S
ENSURE THAT WE GET MEDICARE FOR
ALL OF OUR UNDOCUMENTED
COMMUNITY MEMBERS WHO ARE ON
THE FRONT LINES OF OUR- BECAUSE
IDEA OF OUR ECONOMY AND ALL
THAT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MA'AM. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WE
WILL GO TO. ONE TWENTY YOU ARE
OPEN. WELL MY NAME IS CHRIS
STARTING ON THE PROGRAM LEAD
FOR THE BY TELLING YOU SEE
KEEPING- AT LIBERTY TOWERS I'M
CALLING TO ASK YOU OPPOSE THE
ELIMINATION OF THE DENTAL
MANAGED PROGRAM. FOR MY
COMMUNITY IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. FIVE ONE TWENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. DOCTOR
DART DURANGO AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THAT SAYS MY CAL WITH
THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY AND I PROMISE THIS WILL
BE THE LAST WESTERN CENTER
APPLICANT ON THIS CALL TODAY
PROCEDURE IN THE HOPES OF- I'M
CALLING ABOUT OUR HUMAN
SERVICES PORTION OF THE AGENDA
OF COURSE- AND- I JUST WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE AND THE
STAFF. FOR THEIR HARD WORK
DURING THIS TIME IT'S BEEN
OBVIOUSLY VERY- YOU KNOW A LOT
OF HAVE YOU KNOW OF A BUDGET
SURPLUS OPENINGS THAT WE HAVE A
SURPLUS OF WORK TO BE DONE AND
WE APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK THAT
THE MEMBERS OF THE STAFF HAVE
BEEN ENGAGING OFTEN ON THIS-
AND- WE HAVE ONE OVERALL
COMMENT WHICH IS THAT. WHILE WE
ARE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
INCREASE FUNDING FOR- ITEM FIVE
ITEM TEN AN ITEM TWENTY TO THE
H. STAFF HOW THEY SUPPORT
PROGRAM AND GUARANTEED BASIC
INCOME- WE STILL HAVE
OUTSTANDING QUESTIONS RELATED
TO THE LACK OF TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE FROM ADMINISTRATION SO
WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO
GETTING THAT HOPEFULLY IN A
TIMELY FASHION SO THAT WE CAN.
ENGAGE WITH THE COMMITTEE AND
WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION- AND
THEN- WE ALSO APPRECIATE THE
INCLUSION OF THE ACCOUNT WHICH
OVERPAYMENT LANGUAGE IN HERE
AGAIN WE LOOK FOR TO NEGOTIATED
WORKING THAT LANGUAGE OUT
HOPEFULLY THAT COULD BE
SOMETHING WE CAN DO AND THEN
FINALLY AS HAS BEEN MENTIONED
IN OTHER CASES- WE ALSO HOPING
THAT THEY'LL BE YOU KNOW THE
ADDITIONAL WORK IT WILL COME
FORWARD. AROUND TOWERS GRANTS
BUT WE APPRECIATE THE
MINISTRATIONS PROPOSAL ON THE
ONCE RESTIVE BY ALSO BUT WE'RE
HOPING THAT THE LEGISLATURE IN
THIS SITUATION GIVEN THE
SURPLUS AND THE HISTORICALLY
WILL GRANT THE POLL PROGRAMS
HAVE BEEN OPERATING UNDER THAT
WILL BE ABLE TO INCREASE THOSE
GRANT POTENTIALLY BY THE TIME
WE GET TO JUNE FIFTEENTH. SO
THANK YOUR TIME DOCTOR AND
OTHER MEMBERS AND- WILL SIGN UP
ABOUT. THANK YOU SIR. NEXT
CALLER. THANK YOU. ONE TWENTY
NINE YOU ARE OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS JUDY AND I IN THE
SCHOOL NURSE FOR THE ROBO
SCHOOL. IN SACRAMENTO I AM
CALLING TO OPPOSE THE
ELIMINATION OF THE DENTAL
MANAGED CARE PROGRAM IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY I ASK YOU TO
PLEASE OPPOSE THE ELIMINATION
OF THE DENTAL MANAGED CARE
PROGRAM. FOR MY. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. ONE HUNDRED
THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
YOU ARE OPEN ONE THIRTY- GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CONNIE
ARNOLD AND- I'M A DISABILITY
RIGHTS ADVOCATE FOR THIRTY PLUS
YEARS AND I AM OPPOSED TO THE
LIFTING OF THE TRAILER BILL
TRAYLOR LANGUAGE ON ETV ON GPS
TRACKING. AND I'M ACTUALLYVERY
DISAPPOINTED IN IN- THE BUDGET
ITEMS THIS YEAR BECAUSE I
REALLY FEEL THAT WHEN IT COMES
TO I. HSS THERE'S BEEN AN
INSUFFICIENT. NUMBER OF ITEMS
THAT ARE NEEDED FOR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT FOR PERSONS ON AYE
HSS AYE CHIP AYE HSS RECIPIENTS-
AND I THINK YOU NEED TO TAKE A
SERIOUS LOOK. AT THE STATE
AUDITOR'S REPORT AND UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE'S A SERIOUS SHORTAGE
OF PROVIDERS. AND THE IDEA OF
THE DISABILITY COMMUNITY WAS
NOT NECESSARILY AS A CAREER
PATH AS I AGES THAT PROVIDERS
TO GO INTO HOME HEALTH. BECAUSE
WE DON'T WANT TO SEE THE MODEL
OF THE- THE MEDICAL MODEL FOR-
I AGES THAT HAPPENED ACROSS THE
STATE- REALLY I PERSONALLY FEEL
THAT I AGES THAT. AND H. C. B.
S. H. C. B. S. WE NEED TO BE.
DEVOLVED FROM A MEDICAL MODEL
EVEN THOUGH I AGES THAT
FOLLOWED THE SOCIAL MODEL WILL
BE WE SEEM TO BE GOING ALONG
THE WAY OF. CAREER PATH FOR
AGES THAT PROVIDERS TO MOVE UP
THE LADDER TO HOME HEALTH BUT
WE NEED LONG TERM WORKERS WHO
ARE WILLING TO WORK FOR US IN
THE COMMUNITY. SO I HOPE THAT
YOU'LL BE ADDRESSING THE
WORKFORCE SHORTAGE ISSUE- AS
STATED IN THE STATE AUDITOR'S
REPORT BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE
LITERALLY. GOING WITHOUT CARE
AND NOT GETTING THEIR MEAT
NEEDS MET AS ELL AS NOT
HAVING- COMPETENT INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE NON RELATIVE PROVIDERS
PROVIDING THE CARE- COMING
THROUGH THE DOOR FOR INTERVIEWS.
AND PART OF THAT IS THE
PROVIDER WAGES THERE NEEDS TO
BE A DIFFERENTIAL IN PAY FOR
PROVIDERS- WHO WORKS FOR THOSE
WITH SEVERE DISABILITIES WHO
DON'T HAVE A RELATIVE PROVIDER
AND DON'T HAVE- YEAH AND
ACTUALLY HAVE MULTIPLE
PROVIDERS. OF ONE OR MORE WHERE
AT LEAST ONE IS A NON RELATIVE
PROVIDER ME PROVIDER. AND THERE
ARE MANY OTHER ISSUES IN THIS
BUDGET THAT WERE NOT- GOING IN
THE DIRECTION I THINK WHERE WE
NEED TO GO FOR DISABILITY CIVIL
RIGHTS AND THE INDEPENDENT
LIVING MOVEMENT ALTHOUGH I KNOW
THERE ARE SOME IMPROVEMENTS AND
THERE ARE SOME GOOD PROGRAMS
OUT THERE ASKING FOR FUNDING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
MA'AM THE CALLER PLEASE. PINE
EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. MAYBE
YOU ARE OPEN. ARE YOU MUTED
LINE EIGHTY ONE MORE TRY PLEASE
GO AHEAD EIGHTY. MOVING ON
MISTER CHAIR WITH THE LINES
INTO WHETHER. BECAUSE AT.
CALIFORNIA ACCORDING A FEW
ITEMS TODAY SUPPORT THAT SHE'S
THIRTY FOURTH AND FIFTH AVE
EACH APPLICATION OVER TO THE
AGE OF SECULAR CRACKLING ISSUE
NUMBER FOR AGES THAT CAR
SHARING ISSUE THIRTY EIGHT IN
THE NATION THANK YOU FORTY
SEVEN REJECT THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE ISSUE PRETTY THANK YOU
FOR SUPPORTING THE GET. ISSUE
FIFTY NINE EXAMINATION AT THAT
THE POSITION OF THE SUSPENSION
OF THE PROVIDER RATE INCREASE
BUT INVESORS TYPICALLY
DONATION OF THE TO THE AGENT
THAT ATHLETES LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE THE
DEPARTMENT IN THE
ADMINISTRATION SUBJECT OF
BECAUSE OF DIFFICULT OLYMPIC
PITCHER AND COMMITTEES ON THE
SUPPORT OF- I AGES THAT
PROVIDED IN THE BUDGET THIS
YEAR AND THEN LASTLY BUDGETS
CONTINUE TO URGE THE COMMITTEE
TO LOOK INTO ANYTHING THAT-
BELIEVERS AT THE NURSING HOME
AT THE NURSING FACILITY THANK.
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU MA'AM. MEXICO PLEASE.
BY THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIRTY TWO ARE OPEN. THIRTY TWO
IS YOUR PHONE UNIT. WE CAN HEAR
YOU THIRTY TWO PLEASE CALL AT.
ONE MORE TRY FOR LINE THIRTY
TWO. OKAY NO ONE WILL GO TO
LINE ONE HUNDRED THIRTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WELL MY NAME
IS SHEILA. AND I AM THE SENIOR
PROJECT MANAGER AT THE CHILD
ABUSE PREVENTION CENTER I'M
CALLING TO OPPOSE THE
ELIMINATION OF THE DENTAL
MANAGED CARE PROGRAM IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY. I ASK YOU TO
PLEASE OPPOSE THE ELIMINATION
OF THE DENTAL MANAGED CARE
PROGRAM FOR MY COMMUNITY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. HI MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE
EXHAUSTED THE QUEUE. OPERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE DO ONE MORE
SWEEP TO SEE IF THERE ARE ANY
FINAL PUBLIC COMMENTS.
ABSOLUTELY ENTER THE FINAL
REMINDER LEADERS IN GOVERNMENT
TO MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT AT THIS
TIME ON ANY OF THE BILL'S
PROPOSED PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE A
COUPLE RE QUEUEING WE WILL GO
BACK TO ONE THREE TO THIRTY TWO
SKEWS ME PLEASE GO AHEAD THIRTY
TWO. GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE
AND THIS IS DOCTOR CAN
UNDERSTAND YOUR PART TIME
INCOME TAX MEANT TO COME IN TWO
K. MAKES TROUBLE KING AND CAN
MANAGE QUE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. Y. AND
ONE OH NINE YOU ARE OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS TONY DEADLINE I WORK
WITH INNOVATE PUBLIC SCHOOLS WE
REPRESENT HUNDREDS OF
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES AND
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS AND
WE'RE ASKING YOU TO INVEST
FEDERAL FUNDS DIRECTLY IN
COMMUNITY BASED NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS PROVIDING AFTER
SCHOOL LEARNING AND SUMMER
ENRICHMENT OPPORTUNITIES. WE
ARE FACING ENORMOUS CHALLENGE
WE KNOW THAT SCHOOLS CAN'T DO
IT ALONE THE PHYSICALLY WE ARE
ASKING YOU TO SET ASIDE ONE
POINT ONE BILLION FROM THE
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN CAN BE
MADE DIRECTLY AVAILABLE FOR
NONPROFIT COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION. PROVIDING AFTER
SCHOOL LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES
TO PROVIDE A COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT FOR THE ACES AND
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY LEARNING
PROGRAMS USING PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT FUNDING THREE PASS
AB ELEVEN TWELVE TO STABILIZE
AFTER SCHOOL AND SUMMER
PROGRAMS AND FOR INVESTMENTS
LEAST TWENTY FIVE MILLION IN
ONE TIME FUNDING TO THE MENTAL
HEALTH. SERVICES ACT GRANT
PROGRAM THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. AND AGAIN WE ARE HAVE
EXHAUSTED THE QUEUE WE WILL DO
ONE FINAL SWEEP OPERATOR IF WE
MAY FOR ANY FINAL PUBLIC
COMMENTS. AND AGAIN LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN TO MAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THIS TIME PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. ONE
FILED BY ZERO TO MAKE PUBLIC
COMMENTS. MISTER CHAIR NOBODY
IS KILLING UP THANK YOU I WILL
TAKE THATAS THE CONCLUSION OF
PUBLIC COMMENT BEFORE WE
ADJOURN TODAY I AGAIN WANT TO
THANK STAFF FOR ALL THE HARD
WORK THAT IT TAKES TO BE ABLE
TO GET HERE. NICOLE VASQUEZ
ANDREA MARGOLIS ARE AFTER TIPS
TOWARDS YOU WITH THAT WE ARE
ADJOURNED TODAY.